[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
okay so uh folks today's guest is a
special one we uh brought him here from
Wall Street Big financial analyst hedge
fund manager expert we're going to talk
a lot about ETFs uh credit swaps uh
stocks bonds mutual funds
it's the one and only Andrew in the
house yes I'm here baby how you feeling
yo thanks for having me thanks for
coming out for sure for sure funny as
hell man thank you man I'm enjoying your
content very very impressive yeah I can
literally sit there and I watch him like
this guy is a ridiculous Communicator oh
maybe one of the best storytellers out
there man dude that's so funny because I
was saying that about you
no I mean that way like the way that you
communicate is through story it's like
if you look at great and I want to
compare you to politicians but if you
look at the most effective politicians
they answer every question with the
story yeah and it's about it's like
biblical you know it's like why would I
tell you what it is when I could show
you so you're on it I appreciate that so
these guys know who you are they're in
the comedy space I know you from a fan
standpoint okay they know you from uh
comedic stamps stand up okay how did you
get started tell your story how you got
started okay so I'm born and raised in
New York I uh I was I surfed when I was
a kid randomly I was born and raised in
Manhattan but I like surfing and uh so I
was like all right for college I'm gonna
go to a school where I could surf so
I went to school UC Santa Barbara oh wow
and uh my fifth year in college there I
was managing a restaurant that had a
comedy night randomly and they asked me
if I went to try and I always loved
comedy but I never was like I'm gonna go
do that I always thought it was a weird
thing to go I'm gonna go on stage and
talk in front of people even though I
admired it so much so the fact that
somebody kind of asked me I was like
okay maybe this is like the uh excuse I
need and I tried and I [ __ ] loved it
and I came back and I just never never
looked back prior to that nothing never
ever never wrote a joke
so now in school if I'm in high school
with your 10th grade 11th grade who were
you yeah I was trying to make everybody
laugh okay I was trying to get attention
for sure and I was busting balls and I
always enjoy busting balls and I love
comedy I mean like I got hustled into
the uh into those [ __ ] um into the
tapes to the Russell Simmons deaf Comedy
Jam didn't you definitely oh yeah but
you you did a little bit later
I did it yeah junior did it on the same
that's right that's right but so when we
were kids he had this great like
basically you you I got my dad to sign
me up and it was like a monthly thing
where they gave you a new tape every
single month yeah right like and so I
didn't even know it was that I just
thought we were getting one they just
kept coming in my dad was like what the
[ __ ] is this so we just had this stack
of just absolutely horrendous offensive
jokes that we found hilarious but at the
same time Def Comedy Jam was like just
taking over yeah like when you did that
how much how much times you have how
much time yeah what do you mean on the
stake oh they were like dudes 10 minutes
they cut it to like a five minutes yeah
it was cut to why is that is that like a
model was that a structure did they put
a lot of guys on or I think it was
probably better it was like let's just
take the best five take the best five a
lot of these dudes didn't even have time
A lot of these guys had it takes time to
put together like an hour of material
where you could like tour you know
that's a big thing in the comedy world
the time you get so you start with two
minutes yeah you get five maybe you get
ten yeah when you can get to 20 half
hour like people I'm working on my hour
I'm working on my hour you know what
that's like well you need an hour to
tour yeah you know like the way that we
make money is by going on the road now
we have podcasts and all these other
things before that it was like
you know you're like a stripper like
it's just I got this weekend in
Milwaukee and I need to make that money
and they're gonna pay me fifteen hundred
dollars or two thousand yeah and it
sucks about those Andrew because you
know listen when you're not when it
ain't yours and you have no Hands-On
[ __ ] like you know like the Netflix and
all these people yeah over there you do
it you leave there's a room of people
that are picking your [ __ ] for you
you're like yo can I edit my can I be in
the room to edit yeah I know what's fun
y'all you know you're just another not
talking [ __ ] about editors but that's
the most vulnerable thing man and that's
the trickiest thing when you're building
a business is like
maybe I would say this that's the I
think that's the biggest issue with
Hollywood right now is like the people
who come up with the ideas for the
movies are so far away from the
execution of the movie wow and the if
you look at the films that actually work
it's usually like writer directors yep
right they see the whole thing through
like even not even write a record like
you look at a guy like Tom Cruise Tom
Cruise is like the only actor that gets
final edit
so that means you can't even put a scene
in unless he says okay that's badass
that's some crazy and that's why every
Mission Impossible
right yeah he made nine how many
missions
it is I think the mission's possible
Right like every one he wins Michigan
but we still watching it everyone he got
to pretend like he's not gonna do it we
believe it every single time I think
it's gonna happen this time yeah so
Cruz's same status right so you would
call him like a saint status guy that he
gets to do whatever he wants to do who's
me who's sane status in your world right
now comedy Hussein status I mean
Chappelle has won Dave who else is there
same status in comedy
do whatever you want Dave can do
whatever you want Joe bill I think Bill
Burke Bill burka say whatever the hell
he wants I mean Louis went through his
ship I mean loot bro I would still go
and put money to see somebody like him
and I would put money to see Bill Lewis
again all these guys would you put Ricky
Gervais as a yeah Ricky's up there for
the whole year even with Louie is and
Louie would say like you know I think he
even said it like they're probably not
gonna make a movie with him for a while
yeah like Louie's gonna need to make his
own hit and then Hollywood will go okay
welcome him back yeah yeah which is I
mean that's business that's the weird
thing about it like I don't know like
the more I
when you when you don't have any success
Everything feels like it's an organized
attack right and then when you start to
have a little bit of success you
understand like how business works it's
a lot of people just trying to not lose
their job yeah you know so like before I
was like oh Hollywood's trying to put
all these these weird ideologies and
movies and convince everybody to be this
way and it's not it's just some guy who
doesn't want to lose his job so he hears
your edgy joke and he's just like I
could get fired my kids are in private
school I just bought this house I can't
afford all right cut that [ __ ] joke
yeah and
scared money don't make money which is
why a lot of those things flop but at
the same time I have empathy for people
who they don't love the [ __ ] movie
they love their kids and [ __ ] they want
their kids to go to school so so you're
not into the whole Disney what they're
doing you know the woke stuff that what
they do hasn't Disney always been woke I
mean my favorite Disney movie when I was
a kid was about like a middle eastern
dude which one was it
I even know what he was I thought
Aladdin was white
When We Were Young it was like Mulan a
lot I didn't even know there was white
people in yeah there was one white it
was like Arielle was like a fish and
white yeah
mermaid she was white and white people
were the best swimmers like that makes
sense like there's not gonna be
yeah
so it's like I I always thought it was
diverse I don't know why everybody's
making a big deal so you're saying
Disney's been woke for a while I would
even call it woke I think it's woke when
you like virtue signal about it
like nobody when when [ __ ] Aladdin
came out nobody was going oh here they
go trying to capitulate to the Middle
Eastern people you know like giving them
an opportunity I swear to God being a
kid
I didn't know that they weren't White
I mean I don't think you guys did you
even did you put a two and two together
and I'm Middle Eastern I wasn't like
yeah those sandals are dope like I
didn't I had no idea no I knew it was
Middle Eastern yeah yeah but we yeah but
yeah it wasn't it wasn't a problem until
you get older and where they they
separate Everybody by this and race and
this and yeah so what's happened then
Have We Become softer more sensitive
because you know there's a whole camp
that talks about what Disney's doing
right like their last two movies flopped
yeah this uh stranger World whatever the
movie was called that's a big one 180
million dollars opening weekend 20
they're saying they're gonna lose 100
million then the other one they did is
uh which one is uh uh uh what do you
call it with Toy Story what's uh oh the
um well there's a name Buzz Lightyear
that one's flopped that's back to back
flop and the seal gets fired they lose
their tax status here in Florida so the
santis goes back with them Igor said a
couple comments the other day about the
Santas and uh you know it's it's a very
interesting place parents some parents
are not comfortable with Disney the
brands change a little bit but you know
they've had criticism for a while on
what they've done yeah yeah I think
yeah I think it's something that you
consider it's absolutely something these
these brands are considering right
you're a billion dollar company you're
going to make these considerations but
at the same time like they did that
thing I think Disney did Encanto yeah
was that Disney that [ __ ] crushed
killed it and that's like a Venezuelan
story or something like that I'm not
exactly sure so like
I don't know that's an interesting one
and it's written but like like you said
from us growing up we used to watch what
they would never make today Tom and
Jerry Road Runner and dude they were
trying to kill each other like you feel
me like the coyotes whole life was
trying to kill this [ __ ]
never acne nothing ever worked and Tom
and Jerry this cat was trying to eat
this thing and was the worst cat ever
and the owner was a black chick because
you knew it yeah what you doing that was
the most blatantly like you knew they
never even showed who she was she was a
black chick and that was just a
stereotype black chick that they put in
I don't know I'm just I'm like Disney
you can't [ __ ] with the mouse man
Disney's just Disney's so smart like
people think it's a competition but it's
not like you'll spend you got kids you
have four kids yeah right yeah so like
you have kids no you don't [ __ ] boy
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this is what I knew it was like it was
going to be rough for Netflix when
Disney got in the games because like
have you ever been to Disney World okay
how much money you probably spend when
you go to dinner at least a thousand at
least a thousand give me all the kids
yeah at the hotel six thousand dollars
oh you're talking hotel and everything
every weekend yes four or five thousand
dollars at least four five thousand yeah
how much money will you spend on your
Netflix subscription over your whole
life oh great question that's a good
question probably less than that
I was in maybe yeah and you got six
different people using the same one like
so there's no way Netflix is gonna be
able to compete long term with a brand
like Disney unless they start doing
these like live experience and things
and they have tried they're doing like
stranger things live right you got to
get people outside there has to be other
streams of Revenue like Disney's in
everything so even if they're not making
money off the movies they got money
coming in from Disney World Paris and
they got the merch lines it's like it's
so hard to compete with them because
they can lose you got kids four
different ones not yet
it's it's a so you're going to want to
raise your kids a certain way and you're
you're not gonna want anybody to have
influence over your kids that you don't
want them to have influence up until a
certain point you know what I'm saying
like I got I gotta tell you at some
point you're gonna be like I'm okay if
he's gonna hang out with his uncle but I
gotta tell you something I was messaging
my wife and I was because I was you know
I like to listen to your guys stuff
before I come out and talk to just like
anybody and um
and I was listening to something you
were talking about like living close
to you created your life around where
you live yeah you're like yeah I bought
this building it's a mile away and the
school is 0.2 miles and everything like
that and everything's close and I
messaged my wife and she doesn't know
that I'm like listen to this [ __ ] and
I'm like oh that's fire I'm about to
drive
I'm not gonna drop that [ __ ] on and I'm
looking for the put in the message like
I go uh
I want the studio to be close to where
we live everything needs to be close
restaurants close
everything right she starts to kind of
like argue like if you build your studio
and then it might be a little like
listen if you want to maximize your life
with your partner and your children you
have to keep all that close Okay hours
traveling is wasted time with family
yeah just yes close neighborhood but you
know in L.A everything isn't close like
a school work home social life close
this close I can an hour each way is two
hours away from my kid do you know how
you can change a kid's life with two
hours a day
shout out to PVD
there's still a fire she was so excited
I was like move me anywhere that's so
[ __ ] that's so funny I mean the
difference is the last 20 years I'm
traveling six months out of the year so
finally it's like I want to get
everything to be close you know close to
each other yeah but when you got kids
the only thing you're gonna be like
you're like listen don't talk to that
guy be careful with this because they're
still like can make up their minds
there's still a little bit more you know
flexible on ideas and then eventually
like listen you got to do whatever you
got I don't have control over you
anymore just like us at one point no
matter what mom dad said we have to go
screw up we have to make our own
mistakes and then you're hoping you've
teached your kid enough to process
issues independently and then they're
Off to the Races yeah if they're turned
on by some Disney cartoon or this movie
or that movie that's up to them but till
then that's the part where some people
are uncomfortable with Disney right now
yeah you you feel like as a parent a
little bit uncomfortable with it
I uh
I feel it's my job to raise them
until a point that they can't decide for
themselves up until that point I I
talked to uh I talked to to to Rogan
about this a little bit because you know
I'll let them not be like man the shitty
thing the annoying thing about getting
money
is uh there's less to complain about
like when I didn't have money I was like
affected by every issue I was like oh we
gotta talk we gotta fix this and change
and then I got some money and I was like
man like the Ahmad Geary is a great
place to hang out for a week it's like
do I really want to read this whole
article about abortion or do I want to
go to Utah and look at mountains yeah
that's way better you know and then
Rogan was like when you have kids it
just brings you right back in I go why
he goes he goes because now everything
is affecting the way they see the world
and your kid is going to say something
to you and it's going to [ __ ] rile
you up I got a friend of mine who lives
up in Toronto and his kid he got two
kids and he and he was giving cookies he
gave two cookies to his baby girl and
then one cookie to his son and his son
goes uh his son goes uh he goes he goes
hey
I want two cookies and he goes why he
goes because fair and equal
he goes what did you just say he goes
because life is fair and equal and he
literally called his wife he goes we're
moving back to him you go yeah there you
go listen it's hilarious whatever you
give a lot of time to you're gonna be
more protective of you know it's like
that's you know like a comedy what do
you guys very much uh uh what's a
sensitive side of your world in comedy
somebody uses your joke somebody's
stealing it somebody steals your joke
like you know in your world
like I have Carlos uh like three years
ago I don't know what it was four years
ago three years ago he stole Pat's
wallet he still passed wallet he just
like so we were having a conversation
and you know it's like well do you
realize what he did and what the jokes
and all this on it's on your world that
sense because that's personal that's
yours how dare you take my joke that I
came up with imagine your joke but now
it's your kid your body the sacrifice
the hours the diapers you're like no bro
you ain't messing with this one because
I put 50 000 hours into this you're
gonna put six hours a day you think
you're gonna persuade this no no we're
not doing this intellectual property I
mean I change a school over a simple
thing like this that's why you don't
like China so much because you see what
they're doing with the intellectual
problem well what he said about Tick
Tock was freaking unboxing I believe
that [ __ ] up too it's crazy
that's right
though
it's crazy I was right yeah
hey it just made sense to me in the
moment like I was like man if I had a
social media company this is what I'm
sure America does it's like we got
Facebook Instagram so we could like feed
the algorithm in these other countries
anything we want and I assume what we do
we are doing it with movie and TV shows
for years it's like we're sending out
all our cool [ __ ] and then everybody in
other countries like I want to be a
cowboy I want to be a cool guy I want to
do this stuff it literally ended the
Cold War blue jeans and Rocky was it is
that what it was literally yeah I
thought they ran out of money no that's
part of it because they were spending it
all on Bluetooth bro exactly boom not
the space right now no it was Levi's but
no that culture culture I mean that's
every part of that yeah well if China
can have you seen this stuff for them I
want to hear it yeah yeah basically like
yo China controls the algorithm and
they're showing different [ __ ] to the
kids out there than they are over here
they could get us into this dumb [ __ ]
everybody's twerking making stupid
videos where in China they're doing
[ __ ] math problems and Engineering
but it's so [ __ ] true yeah I put that
[ __ ] out there and I repost it and I was
like man I was on one with this one but
that's what happens with jokes like
sometimes things make sense in your head
and you're like let me just throw it out
there and see and um and then I gotta
[ __ ] says but people in the state
department put it that way got back to
me and they were like yeah that's that's
kind of what it is no [ __ ] so you're now
on the inside with State no no they're
not talking to me directly oh okay
you're getting the same status but I
don't want to be involved
you nailed it because like all the I
think about the American kids here are
doing they're doing the [ __ ] uh tide
pod challenge you know like myself on
fire and like what the [ __ ] are you
doing bro like and the kids are doing it
over there you can't do they're not
watching [ __ ] just yeah science yeah
that's all you're watching our tick
tocks are fire though like that is
pretty dope watching a kid light
themselves on fire that's that's fun bro
if you really want to think about it
that's who did that first wasn't that
like Tibet or some [ __ ] like was it
Tibetan guy the monks viral Tick Tock
[ __ ] was fine that was like man somebody
tape this [ __ ] PVD you've got strong
opinions on what we should do with Tick
Tock at this point you did a whole case
study about you're doing videos on
Instagram that get literally millions of
views get rich and on Tick Tock you're
getting like five views it's like
clearly something's up this is this is
what's gonna happen I mean the tick
tock's got a lifespan they're not gonna
be around forever tick tock's got a life
span you got a year two years one
Republican president away from Tick Tock
being banned in America and you're gonna
be the next Vine and some people who are
not ready for it they're not going to be
adjusting it's already done yeah you
think so yeah YouTube shorts yeah that's
the beautiful thing about like about uh
This is Gonna sound [ __ ] up but kind
of like when like government and uh
social media companies are in bed with
each other I mean you know the game
probably better than anybody but I would
assume once your company gets big enough
the government goes hey now we work
together
and then you go okay it's kind of like a
mafia yeah
but it's like you've reached escape
velocity and now we work together and so
with YouTube shorts It's the exact same
thing as Tick Tock if you look at it
right only it has way more data and way
more American data you're talking about
YouTube which is Google right these are
the number one and two search engines in
the world there's no way that you would
prefer to be on Tick Tock than you would
be on YouTube well brother think about
it in America you know what's the
Chinese TV station that we all watch MTV
there's no Chinese media here it's
because we don't want our kids or our
civilization being indoctrinated by CCP
thoughts yeah but they averted that
through social media through Tick Tock
yeah so at some point who owns Tick Tock
uh bite dance who's owned by the CCP
yeah at some point and this is one of
the things Trump was I got credit for
yeah we need to re-look into this yeah
I'm sure that we're not getting more
into it now bro we don't need it but do
you guys hear so I think it was
yesterday the South Dakota governor um
Christina she banned it from every
agency state agency none of y'all could
use tick tock at all it's all off their
phones
so the South Dakota governor uh Norm she
spoke uh she I think she's pretty isn't
she said it's off our networks it's
blocked off of our servers any state
employee anybody who contacts in the
state of South Dakota [ __ ] on you period
good for her inspector Andrew you know
she's got some Heavies
you know the twins started the Heavies
right did they really that is it comes
from them stop it so what I got in my
life because they do they they
absolutely do yeah
also our good friends
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah have you
interviewed her I'm trying yeah of
course yeah yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't
even you're trying to get her you
haven't I've been messaging her a little
bit but she doesn't know that I always
talk about how huge her tits are for me
I think that's gonna be the
differentiator she's gonna come on the
podcast she's a total sweet but she
doesn't know and she's very sweet she's
in my neighborhood you know how small
she is what you know how tiny she is not
Oliver what she's maybe yeah 85 90
pounds really are you sure first of all
first time we go out to lunch and Adam
you've been out to lunch with her yeah
so we go out the line is there a
restaurant where they serve rat in
America for sure so it's crazy like you
know I'm actual
Yard House we had a red burger
by the way it's so funny so we're
sitting there on me man she meets Adam
for the first time this is Adam's the
first time what she says to me no no the
second time because we spent the whole
day together we were filming content
that's right that's right and what does
she say to you she goes hey uh you gay
you're gay right
I said I said what by the way she's
we're in front of everybody she's like
Adam you're just so nice you look so
good you're gay right I said I said
yummy what say that one more time you're
gay I said no I will take your little 85
now I'm gonna show you what day is my
God you know me but she's an absolute
sweetheart yeah yeah gosh her story is a
a crazy story yeah the fact that we're
talking about her real talk yeah the
fact we even know her name when we're
talking about her yeah escaped
don't delete it look go back to what you
had there that's what Rob had okay
Parks plastic surgery did you get a
breast implants oh my goodness no I
genuinely believe that we have changed
Google
by talking about this so much her and
Nancy Pelosi like now now Nancy if you
just type in Nancy pelosis see what else
comes up bro you were the first person
to recognize she's been at politicians
for 50 years I have her picture on my
Dad shows up he's like heavy
unbelievable set of tits on that they're
ridiculous bro yeah yeah she's 82. yeah
cannot be here she really 82
when she was 21 she must have been just
a killer crazy killer have you seen her
at 21 or something meeting John F
Kennedy oh yeah I know that have you
seen that picture can you find that Rob
find Pelosi with John F Kennedy yeah and
then see what she looks like
see what she was right there zoom in
what yup yeah
and look at the smile on his face damn
right
[Music]
how would a Nancy Pelosi end up meeting
JFK in 1960. this all makes sense
imagine I have no clue
he said he could get a table of Carbone
it's a hard find here in Miami 100 how
many girls have you said I can get you a
table at Karma eight o'clock
ten o'clock around forget it I'll never
forget what me Adam the first time I'm
chilling with Adam we walk into a to a
place where Miami or one of these spots
remind you Andrew I'm like I'm new here
I'm just I'm from the East Coast I'm
just like trying to come in and as right
we walk in I'm trying to like we got our
ideas and I'm trying and I'm like so
Adam who are gonna Adam's already in a
group of girls like yeah so then that's
Vinnie in a huge this cat doesn't weigh
Carbone anytime
he already sold the resume to me like oh
it's a comedian from now I'm like God
damn he doesn't waste anything okay I
gotta quit do you have daughters I do
okay
I because I was living here for four
months I was concerned about raising
daughters here
it depends on where you're raising them
you're not raising them in a club bro no
but still it's like Miami you get caught
up in things like I lived here for four
months right and I almost got caught up
a little bit I was like oh I want a
[ __ ] I want a car I think
I wanna I wanna old car like I want a
stupid old car I got the 64 Thunderbirds
no I wanted anything a Chevy Astro I
wanted a Speedster
okay and uh a 1957 Porsche Speedster and
I got I ended up getting a fake one
because I wasn't gonna spend half a
million dollars on a [ __ ] car James
that's a sick car it's a [ __ ]
beautiful you have it you got it I got a
fake one yeah what color uh the one I
got was it's like a British racing green
with a chance now I know do British
racing green German car it's a little
whatever yeah it's fake anyways yeah but
no one knows the difference by the way
just so you know that it's the same no
one knows the difference yeah so what
does this have to do with Miami my point
is like I meet I grew up in New York I
didn't get a license since I was 20
years old I couldn't give a [ __ ] about
these things I'm almost being influenced
so if you're a young girl here my goal
in life is that my daughter doesn't [ __ ]
a guy drive an orange car right like
number one if there's no orange car if
an orange car pulls up to my lot and I
know my daughter's sucking a guy's dick
in an orange car this is like
heartbreaking for me and I failed I
think you have to be more worried about
your daughter watching Disney than
living in Miami
yeah hold on are they making movies
about orange cars
is it not a Magic Carpet anymore it's a
[ __ ] orange Lamborghini what do you
live right now it was just like it was
so tacky and I'm like there's no way
that you like this thing what's going on
it's just look at me look at me nobody
even knows what the [ __ ] is going on
under the hood there's no appreciate
appreciation of it all it's like I
completely care about consumption and
that's it the value it brings me and I
got a little scared and I was like would
my could I instill enough values in my
daughter could my wife and so enough
values in in our daughter that she would
look for a guy that uh treated her
kindly and loved her and cared about her
and wouldn't wouldn't be influenced
Maybe by her friends who are like no
let's just go to the clubs blah blah
blah so do you have a daughter no no no
hypothetical daughter that you don't
have you don't you get married yeah you
gotta plan a little bit 100 gotcha you
know so what was your experience like in
Miami I loved it I loved it
where do you live now uh in New York you
live in New York yeah are you thinking
about moving here or no no no I really
liked it and I was trying to I was like
can I do like six months six months
seven months six months like Miami
embraced us in a way that was
it was unbelievable like Miami's one of
these really cool places and I'll give
them this and I think it's it's like
Miami's like Latin America's version of
America you know how like Hawaii is like
Asia's version of America yeah yeah like
you go there you're like this is America
but is it like that is what Miami was
and with that comes this like incredible
like uh like welcomingness right where
in New York everybody's trying to act
like they're not impressed you know and
in L.A people are just so absorbed with
whatever's hot doesn't matter if it's
like quality or not it's just like this
is a hot thing but here it was like oh
you've moved down here dude you gotta
come by the restaurant or dude you got
to come by the office like everybody was
so inviting about every like even
getting a coffee oh this one's on us and
I was like wow this is like a beautiful
place I want that I want my kids to feel
that so I I was very close I was very uh
are you at a phase of your because right
now you can live anywhere you're gonna
do specials and do well right you don't
have to be in New York or do you see it
as a career thing it still makes sense
to stay in New York and not move to
another place for stand-up New York buys
a couple things it's like one I can get
on stage more and probably better
quality stage time quality stage time
means not like the people here are
quality but there's like five or six
clubs that can do four or five shows a
night instead of maybe in a city like
Miami there might be like one show at
night that's like really good got it and
the other ones you're not even close to
be honest yeah right someone that does
stand up in Miami like New York is like
Head and Shoulders above any city in the
country yeah and L.A might be just a
little bit less I mean New York is the
mecca but like in L.A I could I could
have done Factory Store you know an
improv Yeah
Austin caught up to L.A no no I don't
know who's third is Austin third in this
if it's New York L.A who's third Chicago
I mean I would probably do Austin before
Chicago yeah I mean just because you
know Rogan has just so much energy
around him and so far he's picked like a
few things to do in his life and then
been the best at all of them yeah so
it's like I think he'll figure out like
a thing he'll figure out comedy out
there who's not gonna go flock to where
he's at Honors that warm if you're smart
you got to do that 100 especially if
you're coming up yeah not established
exactly yeah so like and the other thing
for me with the podcast is I like having
guests and you know it's it's harder I'm
sure you guys go through this like if
you're willing to travel maybe you can
make that happen but you know I I want
to have these guests and when you're in
a New Yorker you're in an LA these
people end up kind of blending in
they're there and it becomes a little
more convenient so I like building that
and also just I was too happy down here
to be honest with you I know that sounds
like a joke but it was like genuine like
I didn't think of a single joke for four
months because you kind of want to be in
a state of miserabeness complaining and
curmudgeon ah this mother somebody's
complaining yes and you're doing it in a
funny way so people tolerate it but like
in in like Miami it was just everybody
there the vibe was like in perspective
because life is good man life is really
good literally
it's like what are you doing okay
brother it's okay I found myself like
writing Joe's jokes about like the
driving being bad and I was like I need
to go back
we're getting the [ __ ] out of here right
now yeah I'm leaving right literally
that was why because down there was like
everybody was like spend time with your
family
enjoy have and party and I was like I'm
not pushing back against any of this I
want a party the lifestyle is so much
better in Miami yeah but if you're still
in Grind Mode dude you got to be in New
York for that phase I like pushing back
against outrage especially so how about
we do this if I have your permission
guys yeah why don't we complain a little
bit why don't we do it I'm serious like
this honestly we're having a little too
much fun yeah Rob I want you to pull up
what I just texted you put it up none of
you guys know I'm putting up the story I
want to see what you're going to say
about it tell me if there's logic in
this if it makes sense uh uh pull this
one up I don't know if you guys have
seen it or not this story just came out
okay
so U.S women's soccer team will pocket
at least six and a half million dollars
uh from the men's team reaching the
World Cup knockout rounds more than they
received for winning two successive
World Cup so did you guys understand the
story so they get 13 million I'll read
the U.S women's National cup so uh right
there the Men's National Team is now
guaranteed a prize of 13 million dollars
after his 1-0 win they're going to go
into the final 16 meaning the U.S
women's national team will take a cut of
six and a half million dollars if the
men win their match against Netherlands
on Saturday to reach the quarterfinals
they'll be taking home a minimum of 17
million dollars what do you think about
this concept of whatever men do we have
to pay half of it to women I mean Andres
fair and equal that's what it is yeah
that kid he's right yeah no it's I mean
it's ridiculous you know I got to look
more I did a whole piece on the U.S
women's national team when they were
complaining about the about getting the
deal that they wanted uh which a lot of
people don't know is they bar they asked
for their original deal they were the
ones to petition for it and then they
didn't want to have it afterwards so we
did a whole piece of that during the
pandemic but yeah it seems absolutely
ridiculous you know I think it's um
yeah it just seems a bit I mean I don't
know get paid what you generate you know
eat what you kill seems like the most
reasonable situation I don't know what
do you think about this well I'm gonna
uh bring up one of Andrew Schultz's
jokes here I'm not going to do a
copyright thing this is yours I'm saying
that up front but in your special
infamous you address these types of
issues feminism you were like the part
in the crowd where you were like I think
we're on the same page here guys yeah
well you know like I went to one of
these feminist marches they're screaming
Free the nipple you're like sounds good
all right you know I think we should
have abortion it's like yeah that'd be
good okay right like you're like um yeah
we need to wait for it
[ __ ] do it yeah right and he was like
are you guys feminists or [ __ ] boys
right yeah yeah that whole joke right
there yeah yeah how feminists are
becoming the men that they hated exactly
yeah and it was such a such an amazing
perspective and the way that you kind of
keep it up with the audience yeah yeah
that's essentially this right here yeah
this is redistribution of wealth though
right and this is something you're not
actually a fan of I assume right you
know why because okay so we we talked to
our expert Malik
and I said who gets paid who gets paid
on the women's side who makes the most
money and Malik out of nowhere says well
women make more money and porn and uh
modeling yeah you watch a little too
much porn movies I hope I hope you're in
the back watching paying attention and
not watching other Clips on your phone
watching if you know what I mean
he's busy check the check you're looking
at least I was about to say no no that's
a rhyme who named him
[Laughter]
[ __ ] white police
his dad's from the Caribbean
that's how you got to name yourself so
they don't think you stormed the capital
they're like
so if you say that's a woman female
models they're making a lot more money
than what are we gonna do let's take it
and split it just doesn't make any sense
go to go to college man that's unfair
64 to 36 yeah we gotta stop women from
learning bro that's a good thing
according to that we should stop at
least 14 of these women going out there
and learning like or I guess maybe the
population's like 55.5 but still it's
absurd yeah you sound very red pilled
right now dude I'm so red pill
manosphere dude dude man so man is
feared dude you've dealt in that world
though you've interviewed a bunch of
these guys know and now it's so it's
like why are you guys so afraid of women
man it's like they're great they love
you it's okay you don't have to be
afraid of them like you don't have to
like dunk on them all the time there's a
lot of great women that are out there I
think I need to see more like married
red pill dudes you know I mean because
there's like it's very rare that I see
like guys in happy marriages just
dunking on women all the time
that's what I said like I'm not taking
advice from uh you know single dudes on
you know how to be with women
straight up huh I mean like if it's how
to get some [ __ ] sure tell me yeah but
if it's how to like build a life and
have children like yeah if you're trying
to get what you're gonna tell me about
getting married yeah you know what I
mean you're not to get married or they
would tell you that marriage is a bad
deal for men or if you're gonna do get
married you're gonna need a prenup I
assume you had this conversation with
what uh fresh and fit in these guys yeah
yeah we had we had with them I just I
don't know I feel like they operate from
a place of fear man and I don't think
that that's healthy I don't want to
teach men to be afraid I think it's more
risk assessment than anything like we're
in the insurance business life is risk
man that's true every time you walk out
the door it's risk you go for it you try
to build something if it doesn't work
out it doesn't work out except if you're
Adam you stay single and you you can get
married Bro all right I'm I'm willing to
to accommodate does she have to be
Jewish no oh really I haven't dated a
Jewish girl in 10 years oh [ __ ] that's
the problem well because Kanye is
telling me stay away from the Jews I'm
like dude
by the way did you see what Kanye just
did I mean this is a wild guy it's rare
that you're on a podcast with Alex Jones
and Alex is the normal
[Laughter]
are you this when Alex Jones is
deferring to extremeness oh God and he's
just like if you get the calm down from
him you're it's unbelievable let me let
me just read let me read it because this
is this just happened so Kanye West
tells Alex Jones I like Hitler this is
what he says he's appearance on
far-right conspiracy theory Outlet Info
Wars uh turn into a chance to uh preach
anti-semiticator now keep in mind this
is a Daily Beast story as the star
formerly known as Connie was praise
Adolf Hitler with the within the first
30 minutes of the broadcast uh ye who
face uh uh was in town whose face was
entirely hidden behind a black mask if
you can show that to Malik Malik in the
back not Malik here began
he's like Philadelphia
so here's what happened he says you're
not Hitler Jones said you're not a Nazi
well I see good things about Hitler this
is what he said later adding every human
being has value that they brought to the
table especially Hitler now this is what
Kanye just said and then he gave
highways he gave credit to highways to
Hitler for some reason yeah he didn't
make highways I don't think Hitler made
highways no I don't think so but he's
trying to say that everyone has
something good about well no Hitler was
known for being very much a if you read
he could make a highway
what what he he was he was a guy that
likes buildings if you read the book
mine comb for some of his material yeah
he was a guy that liked buildings so if
he says that I'm not sure if you build
roads or not but that was his area of
Interest yeah but like okay I'm not
sticking up for Kanye at all but it's
like going off edge like like what if
like in all this craziness if you're
like dude
he bought the 235 consistent he was a
[ __ ] good like yes he did what he did
but did you ever see the guy bull like
he had some good you can't say he didn't
have anything but it's one of those
things where it's like do you need to
say it like exactly that like shut the
[ __ ] okay we don't need to hear about it
bro like like Bill Cosby made a mean cup
of coffee
but guess what he put [ __ ] in it you
know so it's like I don't know yeah I
think that he's trying to be you know
inflammatory the thing about Kanye is
like none of these ideas are his own
like Kanye's Kanye is just finding out
that he's not as good a producer of
intellectual thought as he is of music I
agree and he just what he's always done
is just sampled things and that's what a
great producer will do that sound is
really great that sounds really great
when I blend them together I can make
some of the greatest music ever but now
he's doing that with rhetoric and he's
just trying to get attention which is
what he did obviously with music and
it's just not he's not good enough at it
he's he's not good enough at making
these things go he can make musical he
can take music you would think you would
never listen to yeah and put it together
and you go holy [ __ ] this is a
masterpiece yeah he's not good enough at
talking to make the things that he says
cool and fun now he can be hilarious
it's undeniable the guys even when he's
saying the most [ __ ] up things you're
like holy [ __ ] is he really did he bring
out a Yahoo foreign
did you see that he brought out a net
and a Yahoo because he's talking about
Benjamin Netanyahu that is [ __ ] you
didn't see when I have not seen the same
interview
what you gotta be kidding me talking
about the Israeli Prime Minister yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah hi guys I gotta talk
to my buddy Ben uh Benjamin then yeah he
goes
oh my god dude
so let me ask you how much how much of
this like on Twitter I posted the story
and the guy responds back and he says
something which you know on what
responding to what Matt Walsh said I
don't know if you guys saw that much
yeah Matt Walsh responded and he said I
want to read this to you if you can go
to um
[ __ ] I don't know if you can pull this
up or not uh but I do if I could find it
so he says well what's the difference
between what Connie is doing is that it
zoom in a little bit Yeah if I was an
optimistic man I would at least hope
that Kanye West his mental breakdown and
self uh immolation would persuade
conservatives to stop falling madly in
love with every celebrity who says one
thing they agree with but I'm not an
optimistic man Connie is a former uh uh
uh zoom in artistic genius who's been
unraveling for years now pushed and
prodded Along by people who pretend to
be in his corner it's sad to watch the
whole thing is just sad okay so a guy
said well what's wrong with what he did
when he says all love all people one guy
says Jesus loved all people Matt what do
you say about what he's doing okay so
they're going back and forth right how
much of what he's doing
one guy said it's pure self-sabotage
he's not even aware that this is taking
place is he does he know what he's doing
does he not know what he's doing where
he's self-sabotaging is he self-aware is
there like an outcome this is going to
be my campaign because Trump went out
there and said a few things and then it
worked for him this is how I'm going to
get all this people behind me what do
you think he's he's doing does he know
does he not know what he's doing I think
that he's addicted to attention I think
he's hurt probably like you know you're
you're famous for long enough you've
been taken advantage enough in your life
because people find ways to extract
money from you right so I think it's
very easy to be hurt and feel restricted
and he's probably a guy who wants
complete freedom but he's not willing to
put up the money for it so like when you
look at like you know Kanye's history he
put up money to try to create a fashion
brand and he lost like I don't know 25
million dollars or some [ __ ] like that
so now apparently he's very averse to
ever putting money up so like I got
these ideas I got these ideas but he's
not willing to put the money up so with
the Adidas thing it's like you don't
have to do it with Adidas make your own
[ __ ] yeah oh but you don't want to put
the money up exactly so once you sign
the deal for someone else's money
they're gonna have a say
and that's just what it is I think it's
a gift to give the guy to call him crazy
like we only call people crazy that we
love right like you people love Kanye so
they're willing to go he's just crazy
there's no such mental illness as like I
hate Jews now you know what I mean like
it's not like it's not like you get
depressed and you're like ugh I really I
hate the Jews yeah you know what I'm
saying like it's like you are choosing
to take that anguish or despair you're
going through and like funnel it into a
lens but it's still a choice to do it
and I don't know if we would accept the
same thing I don't know if somebody was
like hating Asians or hating black
people if we would go I think it's
having a little bout of mental illness
I don't know if we'd give that up to
them I think there's two things going on
here with him clearly he's not willing
this is number one clearly he's not
willing to seek counsel or listen to
somebody I'm sure there's people telling
him Kanye bro I've been your friend for
x amount of years I've been a business
party of yours I'm a fellow rapper of
yours I'm a political figure brother you
gotta stop and he's just like don't tell
me what to do dog you can't tell me what
to do like there's that yeah a hundred
percent and everybody's in his corner is
making money off him and that's the
trickiest thing is like when everybody
around you make money off you they're
not going to be honest you're oblivious
you got blind spots but now losing all
this money yeah number two if I may uh
the whole Jewish thing yeah clearly he
was burned by some Jewish business
partners okay let's just back up a
second he's he was worth as of like a
month ago a couple billion dollars they
did all right yeah they were doing okay
for you Kanye yeah but what's transpired
in the last few months yeah okay number
one so these Jewish business partners
record Executives maybe you know took a
little off the top he still was worth a
billion took a little bit then go paper
so these Jewish record Executives go
deeper he's getting a divorce from Kim
sure Kim's lawyer was Jewish oh okay all
right so another Jews [ __ ] with me and
who's Kim [ __ ] after that Pete
Davidson I guess he's kind of Jewish
right and you see what he did now
allegedly you can Google this he is now
converting to Judaism to troll Kanye
that's hilarious this is what's
happening right now
shout out Pete that is
that is really funny converts to Judaism
and latest Kanye troll I don't know what
he went through but like is that way
could you show that picture is
everything hello
here's that real here's the point he's
not willing to listen when even people
he trusts are like dude just whatever it
is I don't tell me what to do yeah and
then he's just double tripling
quadrupling down on the Jewish thing
yeah and then like the business Kim's
lawyer he's now he has to pay her 200
Grand a month okay and that's based on
what he made for the last five years
let's say not what he's worth now that's
how that works yeah and then just to add
insult to injury the skinny tatted up
dude that's been [ __ ] your bit your
your wife yeah uh is now converting to
Judy's into the [ __ ] so he's just got
so much hate in his heart right now yeah
and there's we talked about what uh
power versus force would you please just
explain that and we can even pull it up
right there power versus so this part
this is a powerful book so I read this
20 years ago just go to images go to
images the way it describes it the
difference between power and go all the
way to the right with the colors yeah
click click on it and uh zoom in there's
a smaller one that's not so this is a
book honey you must read today zoom in
zoom in zoom in Zoom is everybody can
see it so there's levels to power versus
Force okay at the lowest level zoom out
a little bit zoom out a little bit zoom
out a little bit yeah all the way to the
left side it starts with shame so you're
ashamed you're humiliated which Connie
is right now humiliated guilt so you
blame he's blaming Kim and everybody
else apathy feel sorry for me nobody
that's the lowest level of power grief
regret maybe he regrets something with
his marriage with career whatever he did
fear he's afraid it's creating anxiety
every low level area is him then it's
got desire he's craving craving
attention which is what Andrew just
talked about right now then it's anger
he's angry produces none of those
qualities are attractive then it's Pride
he's spawning down yeah he won't back
down so the the lowest level of humanity
the first levels that you actually have
some power and you're free it's courage
yeah okay courage to be wrong neutral
let me hear both sides that you're
willing to improve you're accepting
people's mistakes you're willing to
reason love joy and obviously always all
the way at the highest level when you
look at this If Connie read this book if
he was willing if he had the courage if
he was accepting that there's some of it
on him I don't know I think you'd have a
different uh uh way Andrew where are you
at on this you think you're at love all
right man I have no [ __ ] clue I'm
trying to think like this is with your
life in general or this is just with
each uh issue that you come across no
this is this is where you're at with the
way you approach life
this is where you're at with the way you
approach life
you know for a lot of us you know you
start at the bottom and you kind of work
your way up some people are actually you
know naturally at a good level yeah but
some that grew up in shitty environments
and you know upbringing and divorces and
parents and drugs and gangs and
financial issues and you have a lot of
stuff to be upset about and so to
recover from that it doesn't happen
overnight yeah no I I don't know it's
weird I I feel incredibly lucky and
Incredibly grateful
um you know I I hope that I can like
judge people's actions at least towards
me that are maybe unsavory you know
based on what they're going through
um but I think a lot of that comes from
finally maybe achieving success that I
always wanted so I'm not operating in a
deficit but I also remember you know
operating in a deficit and then how you
feel like the world is kind of against
you and you kind of like lash out in
that way so yeah hopefully I'm getting
on that top half right there and you
know definitely some of those feelings
and it's not about money Andrew but a
part of it is right success and all that
like you told the story about how like
when you didn't have money and you know
you were complaining and everything and
and then obviously when you had one
you're like oh YouTube that sounds nice
it's it's a different vibe in your life
it's it's less like the money like I've
never done anything specifically for
money like I always found like you know
chasing greatness the money will kind of
find you but because of like the Rarity
of greatness but like money does offer
this really cool thing which is uh I
won't experience in my life like I want
to know what it's like to completely
check out from
to use the manosphere term if you will
the the the the the Matrix like I want
to know what it's like to do
everything in my life because I want to
do it not because I have to and
um you know maybe from The Matrix is
what you're talking exactly yeah so it's
like the red pill Andrew uh listen I'm
on it but like I believe it's like so
rare because I don't think it's like
very natural to do that as a human so
I'm curious like and I don't know how
much money you got I think I know you
got some money I'm borrowing money from
you
but like but like when you get to the
point where you don't have to work yeah
a weird thing happens you have to find
something that you want it what I've
always done is like I've gone I'm going
to do what I love and find a way to make
money at it because I don't want to do
something I don't love because that's
going to drive me crazy but if I love
something then I can put everything in
it and I can just give it my all and I
just love every day like I love going to
the studio where I love yeah I love
these yeah but what happens when you
don't have to that's what I'm curious
and like do you remember that moment
like was it depressing a little bit like
you almost stop being part of human
evolution
right like up until people weren't
supposed to have hundreds of millions of
dollars yeah right and then you get it
that's how your brain is designed do you
have to trick your brain into thinking
you're still surviving it's it's a very
good question by the way this whole Utah
thing coming out are you talking about
Pete Davidson with uh you know wanting
to be a Jew are you thinking about
joining the Church of Mormon or LDS is
that kind of where you're going with
this is that with the life change
Joseph Smith is that the Direction no
not it's so funny because I went there
for I went there for uh it's a great
place by the way I went there for
Thanksgiving I didn't know it's on
Navajo land oh wow so I'm spending
Thanksgiving on [ __ ] Native Americans
no alcohol dry county I'm not worried
about dry I'm just getting the saddest
Happy Thanksgiving from these
[ __ ] like it is the most tragic
[ __ ] day like it was bro it was
brutal and it's a little chilly in the
morning so like when you're eating
outside they're like can we offer you a
blanket or something I'm like I'm
falling for that one but but no I am
really curious what happens in life when
you can unplug so when you can when it's
a choice a choice right so this is
everything from at least for me I like
things to be a clear systems steps uh
you know where the more clarity I have
the better I do the more distracted I am
the worst I do so the key for me is
Clarity and anticipation is one of the
biggest uh uh uh advantages you can have
if you anticipate like what you just did
right on the podcast you may not even be
aware of it you anticipate it like
what's gonna have my daughter from
living in Miami and she's dating she's
suck and she's going you're thinking
you're anticipating what happens I mean
I was thinking about having a daughter
at 23 years old am I ready to have a
daughter do I want to have that fear I
had that fear at 23 years old you're
anticipating your question you're asking
right now is anticipating I broke it
down in four 20-year runs first 20 year
don't make a big stupid mistake okay
second 20 year go make your money okay
third twenty year pursue whatever you
want creative by choice last 20 year
contribution where you want to go
politics you want to go do you know you
know whatever you want to do that's the
last one one if you want to go to
anything without okay so that breakdown
is okay I gotta make my money first a
guy calls me from Hollywood who says hey
man I watch a podcast closely and but I
can't talk like you think I should open
up a podcast and really tell people how
I feel that's how much money you get in
the bank he says uh about eight hundred
thousand dollars so what do you got in
every asset stocks everything that's
about 1.4 million I said how old are you
35 years old 38 years old I said okay
you don't have a few money yet because
if you do that in Hollywood you're done
you're done if you're Clint Eastwood say
whatever the hell you want to say you
got 500 million dollars on the bank
you're good to go right so that's it's
different for you because you're a
comedian you get paid to talk [ __ ] so
you're a little bit more free to to say
that but
first time I had 10 grand in the bank I
was 21 I had got out of the army
it was freaking awesome first time I had
100 Grand I was like that's pretty tight
first time I had a million in a bank it
was cool it was like this is legit a
million but 10 grand believe it or not
felt more special
first time 10 million it was like oh 10
million you actually felt free yeah
but when it hit a couple hundred it's a
different story
you kind of sitting here like yeah yeah
tell me about that yeah because I I
imagine and I don't know how big your
dream but like there's the number that
is [ __ ] you money for you yeah and that
number keeps growing but I'm not there
yet though yeah well where is it yeah
where is it well well I I don't I don't
think okay so because
um
the Love of the Game let's talk about
the Love of the Game yeah does Joe need
to do more podcasts because he needs
money does Joe need to do like you know
how you watch the UFC what's the best
reaction Joe has with Cormier oh he does
I mean everybody wants to see that right
it's like it's like how LeBron does
whatever he does in the sense he's like
do you just want to see Joe do this
right sick everybody reacts to it you
know there is something very special
about a guy who loves the game he's
playing yep there it's such a freaking
beautiful thing to see you sit there you
say dude I just know you will love your
freaking game yep and I want to watch
you do it I watch you do it I S I feel
the love of the game so for me I draw
from that I'm attracted to that right
and if I see somebody that's doing it
for them I like NBA there's some guys
like I wrote about a guy named Andrew
Bynum wanted to remember I didn't love
the game it was just seven one 260
pounds dude give this guy 100 million
bucks it's hard to find a 71260 guy
right but you see a Steph Curry play the
guy freaking loves the game he's having
fun dude it's Steph Curry may be
to me the most exciting guy to want to
walk because he loves the damn game so
when it becomes about the Love of the
Game it's no longer money you're
pursuing something else so unfortunately
if you're solving money 100 you're
eventually going to slow down if you're
pursuing a true vision cause purpose
Love of the Game it's tough to slow down
every night I come home my kids want to
play Domino we love the game of dominoes
like the Love of the Game for us so
that's how I would explain it to you
also another reason why I don't want to
grow up in Miami Domino's
[Laughter]
in New York though yeah right you're
right no but the thing about love of the
game which is interesting is
you don't know that it's pure until you
make enough money to not play very good
point very good point so it's like Steph
already had enough contracts he don't
got to play basketball yeah so the Love
of the Game for you I'm assuming is
multi-faceted building businesses yeah
but you're into this game as well yeah
and then maybe aspirations of uh
politics
maybe we find somebody like you and put
you in the white house maybe we do
certain things like that first of all
that's big money talk right there yeah
that's big money talk when when when I'm
a puppet you know what I mean yeah
that's that's how rich people talk about
people
broke it will put you in we'll put you
in that is Manchurian no but you know
but you know what it is it's it it let
me let me kind of explain that part in
maybe a different way uh that it'll make
sense to you dude I'm the guy that in
Iran I watched Rocky IV in Farsi a
couple hundred times you know and the
best part in Farsi is in the movie is
what you know at the beginning of the
fight you know I noticed you were you
ruining your address and at the end if
you can change and I can change anybody
can change and he was kind of the whole
concept of the movie was let's bring
Russia us together right unified which
person down in the U.S by the way half
of my family is communist half of my
family at the time was imperialist so my
half my family loved America if my
family hated America so I'm kind of like
[ __ ] yeah this makes sense with me so
there's that pure direct experience as a
kid living in Iran so that passion
experience right now I go to Germany I
live at a refugee camp I'm kind of
watching all this stuff saying man this
is pretty crazy what's going on hanging
out with all these albanians and
Yugoslavian and Czechoslovakia and these
countries don't even exist anymore
you're like hey why are you leaving why
are you living you're learning immediate
education on different cultures right
like it's a uh uh what's the word Fast
Track learn about 40 different countries
in 18 months or 10 years old it's kind
of what happens when you're living at a
refugee camp then you come to the states
I'm the guy that we would leave Wilson
Junior High School and we would walk
down home and it'd be like eight of us
and I'll say Andrew question for you who
do you want to be Andrew you got four
choices you can be the richest man in
the world you can be the president you
can be the best athlete like Michael
Jordan or you can be the best performer
like Michael Jackson who do you want to
be and then you would go
and if we will play this imagination
game but always living in la la land
dreams all this stuff Army camaraderie
grew up together sitting down talking
[ __ ] drinking sarcastic with you talking
[ __ ] to him he can't handle it he's
sensitive so we really go out for a
couple hours we light them up tomorrow
morning got freaking formation you know
that was believe it or not the Army's
filled with great comedians they just
don't know they're great comedians
the camaraderie in the army pay me five
bucks a month yeah but give me a five
you know crew of running mates having a
blast dude forget about the money yeah
so the passion of like this right here
right this is the camaraderie is a very
special thing then I got into business
and I like numbers I like numbers a lot
like to me I'm just looking at the
numbers right in the middle everything
to me is numbers right I'm a I'm a math
guy even I'm a one-pointer GP I got a
love numbers so I got into Financial
Service I'm like gosh numbers are pretty
interesting and then I learned sales
and then I uh learned competition and
then I like Hollywood comedy movies come
Sports combine all those to get us a
dude we're gonna we have to do a lot of
things so for us our vision today with
what we want to do everything
that was on my list I'm in pursuit of
whether I hit it or not I don't know but
I'm and by the way that Pursuit
oh my God it is freaking such a high
yeah yeah like you're in Pursuit right
now you're in Pursuit right like I
watched uh Marcelo comedian that's not
with SNL he was with us for a year he
was working for us yeah Marcelo was his
producer for like every day he was at
our office and I would watch Marcel I'm
like
kid really believes in himself yeah yeah
he's a dreamer you gotta love this guy
yeah and he had a vision too the pursuit
that Pursuit is attractive so the
pursuit yeah you know I'm most miserable
when I'm not pursuing something and that
can be long Pursuits or short Pursuits
yeah it could be a little project that I
want to get excited and I want to
execute but if I don't have a thing that
I'm working towards even if I'm doing
the things that are generally exciting
that I enjoy it's not as fun it's not as
exciting yeah I need that thing yeah I
need the carrot and I and I Yeah the
more the more money you have in
Financial Freedom you have the more you
have to incentivize yourself with the
carrot because it's very easy for the
carrot to be rent
you know but like when you don't got to
worry about it now what's the carrot
yeah which you know I'll tell you like
think about what Elon is doing right now
okay Musk uh musk uh I said I believe
Twitter's gonna be a trillion dollar
company six months ago can I made a
video about it I said if this guy buys
it it's going to be a trillion dollar
company in no time three to five years
it's a trillion dollar come you're out
of your mind Scott Galloway he'll never
even buy his [ __ ] in you guys you
think he's gonna buy it he's just Faking
It you guys are idiots Galloway
Professor Galloway yeah my wife got her
MBA at NYU and that guy's so [ __ ]
annoying there's some things he says
that's good there's some things he says
you're like what are you talking about
by the way you know this guy do you know
this Galloway guy he's got Galloway no
no he's not talking about Galloway he
was by the way in that world he's a god
well he didn't write that that um that
paper about how boys and men and all
this stuff yeah make money be in shape
and have sex yeah and then he got like
[ __ ] on for it I think and then he like
apologized on his podcast
he's like a Michael Porter guy yeah NYU
kind of like I don't know what you would
call that the uh what is it Collegiate
intellectual sphere I think he is you
know he had a show on CNN plus they
crushed it it's I don't know if you
heard about it yeah yeah it blew up so
yeah so but anyways you look at Elon
Elon is now chasing money elon's like I
think I can take Twitter to a billion
active users dude if you take Twitter to
a billion active users 10 pay eight
bucks a month that's 800 million dollars
a month in Revenue that's 10 billion a
year in Revenue yeah bro you don't need
any advertisement you tell everybody
screw off I don't need any of this stuff
then all of a sudden it's a trillion
dollars so so the solution his his uh
method of doing it that works so well he
solves for what is my solution how
difference is going to be he goes and
gathers Intel from everybody he doesn't
come up with all the ideas what do you
think what do you think think and then
all of a sudden he's Rich so but if you
if you flip it and it's only the money
you're chasing you will slow down can I
ask you guys a question do you guys
think angel I'm going to ask all you
guys do you guys think his motive for
the Twitter takeover was genuinely him
going peop we can't even talk was he a
savior for free speech obviously the
money's involved but what do you think
his General like I I think genuinely
like I'm a Christian I believe in God
I'm not overly religious but dude
sometimes God just plucks in these
little people because if it's not for
him you see how what it is in China
about regular Americans don't understand
they don't watch what's happening I know
they're beating the [ __ ] out of these
people they're all they have drones
spraying chemicals and [ __ ] on them
they're they are it's horrible over
there it's slowly this binder you see
what they have with the seat they're
they're kovid lockdown [ __ ] this
contract field would gladly love not to
go that extreme but they would love to
keep us locked down make us just
depending on the government do you guys
think that that's what his motive like
Elon [ __ ] is that he genuinely gives a
[ __ ] about us us and Free Speech I think
so I think it's it's definitely part of
it I don't know what percentage but I
think I think it's also like like buying
a Rolex at retail where he's like even
if you hate it it's not going down yeah
you know yeah so it's like I can't
you're not gonna lose money on Twitter
if you can figure out spaceships he can
figure out [ __ ] Twitter yeah yeah
like let's be honest yeah it's not like
the hardest thing it's like you have the
app where everybody talks that's where
all the news comes out this is the news
he bought the news yeah so uh yeah I
think he'll figure it out and I think
the more active users
the more money it's going to generate
even if he's not charging a monthly
subscription it's like you want to be on
the platform that everybody's on yeah do
you guys think you guys think the
government is going to get involved
because I know the yeah the White House
was like oh we're looking at it closely
oh now because it's somebody that wants
free speech now you guys are all of a
sudden worried about it they can only
play these games for 18 months before
DeSantis gets like they're gonna you
think they've done it yours you get
eight years every day they're gonna have
nightmares
musk they're going to be miserable if he
does go who do you think he's gonna run
with if you had what do you mean right
now who would it be his running mate
right now oh it's you're talking about
VP VP if you had to go right now if you
have to just if you had the like Adam
with his with his Vegas bets what would
you bet right now if you had to because
I I met your Suarez
stop it yeah
stop it right now oh my God all right
all right he's a good guy he's a sweet
guy that's what Suarez president don't
do it
there's no Suarez I love you yeah don't
let him you really think there's no
chance Suarez mayor sworn yeah he's
about to run no but he's gonna run for
president you think that he could how
many votes does he need to win like
Miami 16 000 or something like that
it's like he's about to announce he's
considering running beloved guy okay
mayor Suarez I love you you're a sweet
guy we text okay
don't [ __ ] run for president please I
mean the sincere I love you and I almost
did the coffee talk with you
yes don't run for [ __ ] present please
please don't do that that's a huge step
that's a huge step okay look bring him
back up there run for governor of
Florida they still think that you're
Mario Lopez you hope you host [ __ ]
Entertainment Tonight they have no clue
that you're the mayor of part of Miami
the part like the least interesting one
it's not even the beach get the beach
first
smarts you don't even have beat spread
you got intercoastal I need you to get
Beats before we go president okay how
many votes decide Miami
uh for the City of Miami yeah probably
there's 11 abuelas in [ __ ] aprons go
vote once every four years yeah and they
put you back in it please don't run for
president I love you don't do it just
yeah he's a sweet guy though we had him
on the Pod he's great yeah but back to
your question about Elon Musk yeah I
think uh Schultz over here hit it on the
head if he could figure out how to send
people to Mars in Space yeah he could
figure out an app over here I mean
that's just hello what a passion I'm
saying that but you're saying why and
here's a why the idea the idea that like
nerds can figure out social media that's
true like knowing that creates a social
app can have like a conversation right
right the fact that they've been
successful at that like I'm not saying
Elon is the best uh you know
conversationalist you know what I mean
like you see him on a podcast and he
like malfunctions yeah
right speed up the neural
he's asking is like so what'd you do
today he's like
I woke up
it's just the smartest guy on the planet
you tell me this guy right here
[Music]
but here's the thing with points
you know hearts and stars over here but
he is from South Africa
let's do it Adam let's go adults wants
to get softer we'll get soft no I love
the hearts and mother [ __ ] stop
you're talking about America right now
of course okay good but he is from South
Africa yeah he grew up under apartheid I
think that's something Twitter is a
african-owned business that's true yeah
we support Disney supports Africa yeah
so I think he understands that at the
end of the day like what happened there
yeah but don't forget Joe Rogan Elon
Musk as of like two years ago they were
for sure Democrats yes Joe Rogan was
definitely voting for Bernie no no but
by the way musk voted for Biden and he
just said it last week yeah so that's my
point and then over the last two years
they've seen what's going on with the
woke culture yeah and California and you
know leftists and all that and they're
like that's too [ __ ] much yeah and
then he just all that and everything he
saw in apartheid it's all just you know
like in the same way that Cubans are
often triggered by Democratic ideology
because they come from kids
you have no idea man my girl I have no
idea no idea I had to swim here do you
think you're swimming yeah yeah yeah but
something something about Elon the
apartheid the the free speech whatever
the trigger the human rights it just was
like all right I'm buying Twitter and
that's just kind of work I hope I
honestly I think he has good intentions
with things uh I don't know he does he
strikes me as an honorable man in that
regard so I don't think so politics is
always tricky man like
I never I don't think politics is the
way I think politics is just a
reflection of what the people want like
they're spineless they'll change and I
think that like the scary thing about
politics like politics and like
financial institutions those are the two
ones where like if you have enough
influence and you talk [ __ ] about
they will make you radioactive real
quick like like Joe was fine until he
was like yeah I like that Bernie guy for
president then the next day looking
through every video he's ever done
posting things out here he's this he's
that the Third
you know and the same thing I saw with
um you know Dave Portnoy runs bar stool
it's like Portnoy was was a hilarious
guy who had a Sports website that's how
the world treated him yeah and then he
started doing that
um he was a daily day trader you know
over the panda maybe dollars maybe I
think he was [ __ ] with the financial
markets a little bit and they're like
well no we're not gonna play this yeah
yeah but the beautiful thing about the
the Wall Street bets like the kind of a
Reddit community
is it's decentralized it's not one guy
that you can make radioactive when
you're one dude you're Joe you're Dave
it's like they can bring out everything
in your past and use Quick but I'm so
happy you brought that up we were just
talking about before this just like the
Jerry Jones thing where somebody out of
nowhere bro goes hey
1957. you were standing in a dude he's
standing behind the [ __ ] group with
just white you know everybody looks the
same what was it about what it was about
he wasn't he was in Little Rock Arkansas
pull it up it was uh it was when the the
desegregational the desegregation they
were they were trying to black trash
black these black kids trying to get
into the school like look at look at the
front Jerry Jones bro if you could zoom
in Jerry Jones is in the back bro
standing right there can we just
acknowledge like everybody had great
hair back
but I'm like I'm like [ __ ] Pomade and
things poor Malik is looking at him yeah
but like look at this hair stunning
like like it was a gel was it what is
going on but yo do you see like do you
like think about uh Andrew and he's just
chilling bro this cigarette does not
like black people that was for sure
he didn't even like the cigarette
it's on him [ __ ] it I don't even go to
school here I don't think he's gonna be
that is so this ain't even lit
well like so you imagine like my
question was like those people they
could dig up and they could find so this
has been a this has been out since
1957. and then somebody goes oh you know
what watch this Jerry Jones right there
in the back and mind you he's just in
the wrong place at the wrong time just
standing what if it's in the back I mean
did he say he was protesting there's no
like video here's did you see his answer
or no he says I didn't even know why I
was there I was 15. yeah I was scared I
was gonna get in trouble I have no other
memories outside of that I just showed
up so that's what he said yeah Stephen A
Smith said well he should have said I
heard there was black girls coming to
school you know what I'm saying I was
trying to step in the truck
stop listening I'm trying to try new
things
by the way that would have been funny if
he did say something like that just mess
with him no I was I was dating this girl
Kiki and you know we were like she's on
the other side you don't see her
Kiki what's on the other side telling me
come on come on Cherry oh my God no
Stephen A said originally he says come
on guys you're doing this you're
bringing back back a picture from 60
some years ago when the man was 15 years
old leave this one alone what are you
doing anyways then LeBron today says I'm
wondering how come you guys are asking
all these questions about Kyrie but you
guys are not losing it over what Jerry
Jones said or Jerry Jones's pictures how
come you're not that uh energetic about
that and that's how LeBron was kind of a
uh and then Stephen A came back and said
I one thousand percent agree with what
LeBron said today anyways it's a mess
with a guy 65 years you got a good point
if they want to come after you and
Target you on anything it's not going to
be hard to find anything on anybody
nowadays oh I'm screwed especially my
military days I did some outlandish
drone strikes not that crazy but
not that one uh no I'm just talking
about pictures and Nick I dude there's
[ __ ] out there of me or if they ever
want to bro like they'll just poop and
they got you just don't run for a public
off never that's what Andrew you you
brought up the Rogan thing yeah he
brought up Bernie all right yeah if you
talk about politics right if you talk
about Wall Street Finance man they're
going to come after you who else did you
say uh uh other than politics and
finance yeah okay quite fine and then we
saw what happened with Andrew Tate he
started talking about that who what was
he talking he was talking about about
the you know the metrics and the system
and the Magic World Government order and
they yeah the Matrix canceled them and
it was you know I think take control I
don't know I think Tate's uh uh because
he's a he's clearly a smart and
thoughtful guy and uh he's quite funny
too but uh I think his miscalculation
was he was playing up a character as
comedy as funny people do I mean we all
do it we play up certain we'll say
certain things on this podcast right now
four jokes that are not really real but
if somebody went hey did you really feel
that way I'd be like no you idiot we're
joking around because we're four guys in
a room less than balls I don't really
think Malik is the black guy yeah I just
said that but the tricky thing with with
Andrew and I think the miscalculation
was his business was tied to those
things being his actual beliefs and
truths he's getting 5 million a month
for Hustler's University and it's and
it's tied to him actually speaking these
things as truths and I saw him I think
it was on like Pierce Morgan he's like
yeah I wish I could have maybe redone it
or like delivered it in a different way
but the thing is the more salacious you
go the more attention you get the
quicker you get I think he could have
gotten there uh the same place he's at
now just at like a slower trajectory he
would have gotten there but it wouldn't
have been so meteoric but yeah I think
that's really it it's like he can't say
I didn't believe any of that stuff
because then you lose all that money
that's coming in based on those beliefs
do you think he's gonna fight Jake Paul
if I'm him I wouldn't
why because if he loses it kind of loses
the whole stick I don't think he loses
the stick because I think he's like
smart enough to like think of a way
around it like The Bravery of just going
in there I respect any guy who gets in
the ring I mean it's just it's a you
know if you ever if you ever like box or
anything like that it's like it's this
is the real deal like a lot of people
talk a lot of [ __ ] they don't want to
get in there so I respect him for
actually doing that in general but Jake
is is a jake is a beast bro a lot of
people don't wanna Jake is a beast Jake
will [ __ ] up most boxers
he will [ __ ] up most MMA guys I mean I
think we've already proven that in a
boxing match
I think he'd be the first person to say
like I'm not beating any of these guys
in MMA this is what their expertise is
but he's taking it seriously and then I
imagine Tate who's probably in his 30s
right maybe 35 36 yeah yeah he probably
hasn't fought in a few years like that
that is like a whole transition in life
to go do something to prove what you
were already a world champion kickboxer
what do you prove by beating beating
Jake maybe you get a Payday maybe it's I
think there's a number amount okay let's
say you get 5 million let's say you get
10 million is it worth it I don't know
what the guy's worth but if you got a
hundred million or whatever maybe he's
saying he got in the bank like is it
worth it for five is it worth it to
train for six months your rotator cuffs
[ __ ] up your eye already has issues
like is that worth it for five or could
you take those six months and apply
yourself to another business and make
five I don't know what would you do I
think you're right I don't I don't think
you should fight him I don't think he
should find by the way if and I don't
want to take money out of Jake's pocket
because I [ __ ] with Jake yeah I mean
well no I think I think Jake is uh uh I
put them in a top five best troll [ __ ]
talkers in the game it's uh and he goes
up against people above him and he hangs
it's not like he's calling our people
below him bullying he goes up and he he
can go go up against anybody no I don't
think uh Tate wins here whether he wins
or not like okay let's just say Tate
fights and he wins what are you gonna
say
what are you gonna say take Tate fights
and he wins what changes you're a world
champion kickboxer yeah exactly right
but but if but if Jake goes and he wins
what do you think Jake and more
importantly what does Logan say my
younger brother
listen I I I don't think you do this
fight I don't think it's necessary I
think this whole thing is plenty outside
of this I don't think you do the fight
and you're already coming back like
you've seen listen they're guys who get
canceled yeah they don't have the chops
to come back yeah he's got the chops
like he can speak to
intellectuals and defend himself pretty
well there's some certain things that
they'll kind of like pigeonhole him into
and he's just got to go like all right I
said something was [ __ ] up I shouldn't
have said it but he can hang so all he
needs to do is continue doing what he's
doing now and then he just has to turn
down the dial a few degrees it doesn't
and it's not going to be as funny it's
not going to be as salacious but it
doesn't need to be because he's already
established the name and then he can
continue riding that out he's actually
is interesting things to say he just
said some wild [ __ ] that if he was a
comedian we would all laugh at him in
that question of course okay I had a
joke back in the day that went it was it
was one of the first things that
actually like started my career went
viral on Reddit on on Super Bowl Sunday
I remember it happening and um and it
was um
uh countries that treat women the worst
have the best food and I remember and uh
and and it was this whole long bit about
like like nobody's ever went out to say
like you want to have Canadian tonight
like no whatever it's like the more
women you know you're like stay in the
kitchen the better the food comes out
and this bit this like long crafted bit
I put it out and went viral on Super
Bowl Sunday I'm a comedian if there was
a person who was literally making the
argument that that's how we should treat
women so food tastes better you'd be
like this guy's a [ __ ] psychopath
right and then if they made a lot of
money off of that and they had to stick
to that it's a really awkward position
but when you're a comedian you're going
hey I was just being entertaining and
like playing with things that happen to
be true and are correlated but might not
be like causality and you get away so
it's kind of fun I almost wish Tate
could be like dude I'm a comedian but I
also say really kind of insightful
things so we could still get the fun
[ __ ] that's the that's the card of a
comedian you see it's like I almost want
to go do a couple
get a way longer leash than anybody else
as they should yes that's your job is to
talk [ __ ] modern day philosophy and even
if it's kind of bombastic and ridiculous
and out there and totally extreme it's
like these is jokes yeah and this is I
was talking to uh Jordan Peterson about
this recently but like it's the
importance of play it's like human
beings we like to play with the things
that we're uncomfortable with that we we
fear right like Halloween the whole idea
of Halloween is playing with death like
we're terrified of dying we're terrified
of like our parents dying our children
God forbid dying so we have a whole
holiday which we didn't use to dress up
as like football players used to be like
skeletons and that kind of [ __ ] it was
like let's play with this thing we're
terrified we do it with uh when you go
to like a Disney World or some [ __ ] you
go on these roller coasters you're
terrified of it but we and that's what
comedy really is it's playing with
emotions that scare us ideas that scare
us and doing it in a way where we can
all laugh and experience it in a safe
way so when it happens in real life
we're a little bit more ready that's why
it's existed for [ __ ] probably
thousands of years people been busting
balls forever when you're with your guys
and you're with your guys in the troop
there's no softball jokes no it's the
most Savage thing yeah there's no
question about it
[Music]
sexuality yeah I I I haven't obviously I
haven't done any um any any service but
I wish that
I wish that people could see what the
camaraderie is in these troops because
from my understanding from my friends
who have served my father served
there's no it's like everybody loses
their identity they have outside and all
the oh you're Puerto Rican the the white
guy will say the craziest thing about a
Puerto Rican Americans say the crazy
thing about a Jewish guy and it's like
dude I was a middle eastern in the Army
oh yeah yeah I mean you're talking about
like Let It Rip well I was in 911
you earn your stripes
happening people were like yo benihant
your mom and dad from where these people
are from and I was like oh [ __ ] here we
go but it was great you know because I
fought back if you can if you can take
it it's really gonna build some
character if you can take it oh yeah
yeah late night two o'clock you're drunk
just you know calling each other out
talking [ __ ] yeah but if any of that was
recorded forget it forget about it I
mean it's canceled done oh but those
relationships you you have and those
moments are so beautiful because you're
saying exactly what you feel jokingly to
another person you're not putting on
like a slight facade so then you get to
build these like really deep connections
and that's that's always what I've felt
like even with Comics you see that like
we say kind of whatever to one another
people I've worked with and it's like I
want to build I want to build a world
where we can be almost 100 honest with
one another because then I'm a ride for
you no matter what you're gonna ride for
me no matter what because you really
know me I'm not being a politician about
it I mean that's to be honest with Trump
I think exposed about politics he was
playful up there with a bunch of people
faking and it was so hard to not look at
them when all these other people were
trying to be like like Jeb Bush trying
to be all professional yeah and he's and
he's just Clowning Jeb yeah he's like
look how far down you are that was
amazing because they wake up yeah wake
up he's taking a nap because he's a
comedian I think what you're talking
about because I did stand up comedy for
many years and then I got into finance
and all that but one of the things I
used to always say because I used to
make fun of this person and that person
is like it's not racist if you make fun
of everybody yeah if anybody can get it
at any given time it's not racist you're
just talking [ __ ] the thing with Kanye
is nope it's just the juice I was like
well then you're just an anti-semite and
you're a Jew hater okay and there's no
jokes and there's no jokes there either
that's why it's not that funny Jews yeah
you know that choose control the media
and going off what you said Adam so and
I think the beauty like and going off
where you just said uh Andrew was
infamous is the the special that you did
which was [ __ ] don't it was bananas
to want a compliment to open just what
real comedy is and this is real and I
know you know this and pattern them
appreciate it you opened your special
with crowd work and for all the people
that are out there this guy you're
taping this thing the money's been it
it's it's not like it's
this is a one take shot the guy walks
out he's busting this person's balls the
Latina in the front no and and nailing
off is what you just said you hit
everybody the black guy the Mexican
chick the white guy yeah and and I I
think it's beautiful number one number
two we're they're slowly trying to take
that [ __ ] away from us which is like yo
yo time out this actually brings us
together you [ __ ] are trying to
separate us the guy's going up there on
a special and busting balls like you
were in the cellar or you wouldn't yeah
and it felt it felt like I'm like okay
this dude's having a blast and that's
what I wanted man like what I learned
from from doing comedy is that like and
I'm very fortunate that I have a very
diverse audience like white people found
me after black people and Latinos
because I started doing Guy Code and
then podcasts with Charlemagne the God
do you guys know Charlemagne yeah of
course one of the most brilliant radio
personalities in history and we're doing
a podcast so black people were the ones
who came out to my shows when I was on
the road initially blacks like Latinos
and like some white people know me from
the MTV stuff and then when I did Rogan
and when I started to have more like
viral success online that's when white
people found me so for me I was always
very comfortable also just growing up in
New York just this is how we made fun of
one another like my friend group was
diverse and we were just gonna not make
fun of Dominican kid like he's gonna get
it like everybody else so so what I
realized is that if you're making fun of
someone to their face
and they're laughing is very hard to be
offended on their behalf
you go all this messed up but when
you're doing a joke about black people
and the black people are in the audience
it's the people you know there's Andrew
it's the
watching that interaction and going oh
that's right he's he's racist he's like
Mitch shut up you can't even say if
she's laughing she's [ __ ] laughing at
it and you're pissed off and you're not
and you're you're you're like oh you're
a white person make you're upset about
this leave it alone so what happened
with the special I saw the story so you
sold it then you bought it back you put
all your life savings into it tell that
story uh yeah so we it was originally
going to be with this streamer and I
don't even say who the streamer is
because I got I've put it this way like
they were really great and the guy who
who initially did the deal he was
awesome but everybody has a boss and
everybody's got to look out for their
bottom line and that's why I kind of I
have empathy in that situation
um so basically they allowed me to buy
it back right and same same value
no premium yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so like uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
some technicalities with it but like but
they were very cool to to do that and um
and basically I get it back and I and I
think about how I'm going to do it I'm
like do I just put it online like I want
to make my [ __ ] money back so I I put
it out with this company called moment
and um they basically will just like you
know do these live stream events but I
want it to be like a live event and also
you know and you can continue watching
it for a few weeks and uh we put it out
through them and it was crazy like
that's the importance of story going
back to our initial there are so many
people I'm sure who bought the special
because of the story of like they heard
like stories just touch us differently
like I actually think that's the hack to
life in a way for humans like that's our
earliest version of storing information
like when you tell a story apparently we
had with Dr huberman on the podcast and
he was and I was like can you tell me
about how humans react to stories and he
goes I can't tell you that much but they
did a study and they said that for some
reason when you're telling a story
everybody's heartbeat adjusts at the
exact same time in the story when you're
giving people information some people
might be offended some people might
agree some people might be sad some
people might be happy but but
specifically when information is
presented in a story
everybody's heart goes up everybody's
heart goes down and to me I'm like
that's a superpower like to give
everybody in a room the same emotion
that's like music so anyway people heard
about the story and they really got
behind it and it was just [ __ ] crazy
like I mean yeah it was just awesome
yeah so what's your plans with your next
one
you can use a similar model what are you
going to do next well now we're in this
interesting situation that I don't think
a lot of comics in history have been in
where it's like I know what it's worth
you know so it's like if if a streamer
wants to buy it I know exactly how much
I can make doing it on your own yeah so
like now you got to pay me way more than
that because I could get that on my own
got it and ideally I'm bigger by the
time I do the next one so you're gonna
have to pay me the premium to take it
away from doing on my own then having
freedom to do whatever I want and when
they buy it they own all those jokes
like you can't how what's the legality
of when they buy it performance but you
can tell the same joke again and can and
usually they create like a little
um leeway like a window so they go you
can't sell those jokes for another year
yeah or something like that but they own
that performance of those jokes which is
smart for them because if not we could
you know I could do the Taylor Swift
[ __ ] which is like she's just
re-recording her old songs so that she
can own them because she they
technically just own that recording so
what a beautiful moment in life where
you know when you think oh I'm pretty
sure but when you found out like we're
we're gonna edit your [ __ ] you can't put
these in your life so what a moment were
you feeling I was bummed but I wasn't at
all worried that like I was bummed but I
knew that we could make our money back I
didn't know I was gonna make this much
money that's what I'm saying so now that
was crazy yeah and so Andrew because of
that now you're like bro what a moment
where now I didn't really realize how
the worth of that which I know you know
your worth but now you're like [ __ ] I'm
chilling yeah you're good yeah like I'm
I'm looking at this I'm like man like
Chappelle's underpaid bro yeah you know
what I mean
he's got like 60 million for like what
three maybe 60 million for three
specials and I'm like
you need to get more bro all right I'm
not saying I made 60 million but I'm
saying where I am
you know and yeah put it that way like
so yeah you can make you can make money
and I own it still yeah he doesn't own
it so which not a lot of people maybe
will want to do the tricky thing
obviously about like Netflix or any
streamer is that they you know like it's
hard for people to get to their content
now there's so much competition so it's
like how do they get eyeballs on their
content and you know I tell the people
that I know what the streamers I'm like
you have to be part of culture and
I think the easiest way to be part of
culture is to recognize what is moving
culture and it's like podcast move
culture but what else moves culture like
memes as silly as they are move culture
like the only reason I know of the show
The Mandalorian
is because of the baby Yoda meme I
didn't know the show was on TV and then
I saw every [ __ ] meme was popping up
and people sending me with baby Yoda and
I'm like holy [ __ ] now Netflix has this
stupid thing and a bunch of these
streamers have this stupid thing where
if you're trying to do a screenshot of
their show yeah your phone goes black
can't do it why would you take away yeah
the number one instrument
of of PR done by the people consuming
your can you imagine how many memes with
Dahmer when Dahmer was oh my God that's
already the number one show imagine how
many memes it's like you have to let the
people produce their own content which
drives people to your [ __ ] I agree so
that's just little [ __ ] so so next thing
you do you would do would you do
something like what Chappelle did like a
three deal type of a thing or would that
be your expectation or would you still
say yeah I'm gonna do it myself maybe I
do it myself maybe I do with them they
would have to convince me that you know
obviously one I would want to pit it out
the exact way that I want to put it out
that's without them having any kind of
control over what you put out there so
you want to have full-on like Tom Cruise
talking about this is what I want to say
leave me alone don't bother me okay and
I'm not and I'm not doing that to be
like a [ __ ] edgelord or anything yeah
it's just like I test the material like
I'm on the road for [ __ ] two years I
see the people laughing at it like I
know the line yeah I don't want to tell
jokes that people don't laugh at because
I love making them laugh and I love
making
I love making people happy it's like
it's it's a really cool moment to do
something for a living that like makes
people feel good not everybody gets to
do that yeah and my thing is this as an
artist this is the only R Andrew that
like for instance that you could do your
art somebody else takes it and messes
with the [ __ ] like there's no painter
that finishes yeah and then they go you
know what you use red hair [ __ ] that
you're taking that off the black here
nah dude you're the artist pimp so I
want I'm in charge of this which I think
for a comedy there's if I'm not Hands-On
and I have the final say I'm I wouldn't
I wouldn't put it out yeah I mean I'm
I'm meticulous with the things that I
create like with the special it took me
one day per minute to edit it wow
and the sound was designed in a way it
was one day per minute and like because
I've wanted you to feel
what it's like to be in that room you
and my audience I felt like I was there
that was that that's the audio number
one problem with comedy specials is
comics
give away the the special to an editor
that's not as familiar with comedy so
they don't know how to create the
tension in the room and you create
tension you can do it with different
camera angles like if you're telling
somebody something serious don't cut in
the middle of that push in like how do
humans naturally react when somebody's
telling like a serious moment of a story
We naturally lean in yeah we do create
the push yeah create so it's like and
then when you want to create some sort
of like laughing moment and you want to
give the the audience an opportunity to
breathe pull out show everybody else
laughing as well so like when we're
looking at how to edit comedy I'm not
just looking at comedy I'm looking at
horror I'm like what's tension release
horror what do we do when you're about
to get murdered tight tight tight tight
tight then out read getting killed so
it's like what are the other things that
I don't know that that utilize the same
things and feelings as stand up but
aren't stand up yeah so I could bring
something different you maybe never saw
and sound is the other thing if you as a
performer are giving more than the
audience is giving you the person at
home will feel uncomfortable it's the
reason often or oftentimes like when we
watch like the late night shows and you
see the audience like over clapping for
like a joke that sucked you're like
that's not real like something's off
Alan Kimmel yeah exactly and you feel
uncomfortable yeah you go what's going
on yeah and a lot of times there's
Comics who are killing on stage but they
just don't like the audience right so at
home
it looks like that person is not
acknowledging a lack of response even if
their material is due to how hard comedy
must have been during covid like you're
watching somebody's show and you just
want like why what are you doing stop it
this is uncomfortable I did one I did
one I don't know if you probably didn't
I did one because I just had to get up
dog I was I was losing my mind in LA and
I was in a room a little bit smaller
than this it was for Shantae Wayans and
it's Doug camera her one dude and
there's a big ass TV with like a hundred
people that all paid and I would say the
joke angry which I know worked yeah and
I was just like this and they were like
this yeah eight seconds later and then
I'm doing crowd work on the TV yeah I
was about quick
bro and you're and you're big on stage
too like it works maybe more for the
guys who are doing like one-liners
Steven Wright doesn't need an audience
brilliant yo he doesn't he could just
say it right into it exactly 100 but if
you're gonna be at all animated and
you're are going to be all like
performing these oh this guy's humping
for girls and jumping around and like
you need this whole thing and you thrive
off the energy you're getting from yes
like yeah like I don't know for me did
you even get up bro did you get up no it
was not Miami oh wow
you know everyone these days um you know
speaking of being a comedian bro yeah
everyone these days wants to be happy
about something yeah yeah whether you
want to like get high do drugs whatever
you know chasing sex yeah you know just
whether you're making money business
yeah being a comedian right the the
laughter the getting like doing the joke
that you're working on because it's not
just getting a laugh you sat there you
wrote it you edited you just kind of
went mad scientist on us and yeah you
went psycho Grim Reaper on how you yeah
yeah genuinely come up with these jokes
yeah yeah when you get that joke how
high of a feeling is you know what it is
it's like for me the highest often
the pursuit you know we were talking
about that even earlier it's like
knowing that I'm like onto something yes
like when the joke is I don't ever call
a joke done but when I'm getting in its
final form yes what I'm chasing in that
moment is the kill and that's not as
gratifying because
uh I'm not exploring as much you know
what I mean like chasing the kill is
dangerous because if you don't kill now
you're miserable but when there's like a
new bit that I'm like
like I'm you know I'm like I don't know
you know there's something there yeah
I'm like even now I'm like ah there's
just something so far I've been talking
you know I've been thinking about like
the you know everybody's like the Jews
control the media and [ __ ] I'm like what
is the spin I have on that and um I
remember I was in uh
and I was in I was in [ __ ] Florence
and I saw the statue of David have you
guys seen a statue of David not in real
life yeah of course he's not he's not
exactly hung it well well well well not
only is he not exactly hung I was
looking at his penis and there and they
were like it was like the perfect man
and I'm looking I was like
I was like yeah but he's you know he's
not cut probably he's not perfect like
you know what I mean like what is this
[ __ ] you know garden hose
but but he wasn't you know he's Malik
you want to put up that picture
he was uncircumcised right and I
remember in that moment I was thinking
and I go wow that's so weird that I'm
like judging that and then I thought of
the word uncircumcised and I'm like why
is that a word
because the Jews
like it's just circumcised and Dick yeah
do you know what I mean like we don't
call people ungay
you know what I mean like and in that
moment I was like yeah the Jews would
control the media
for me for me I'm like I'm like okay
here's like a funny like angle
like then I'm like oh this is cool to
explore like it's like one of these
things where I'm like it's like it's
it's it's so rare nowadays that we're
all thinking about the same thing it's
so rare that like everybody's thinking
about so here's something I think
everybody is thinking about and here's a
fun way to address it one that I think
Jews will laugh at and without feeling
like attacked and non-jews will laugh at
because they're like why the [ __ ] my
dick Jewish bruh what the [ __ ] so for me
I'm always us homie yeah if you could
think yeah
exactly exactly so I think there's more
there but yeah but that's like an
example of like not like I'm excited
like I would never tell a joke to some
comics and that because that's not like
done or anything but like
for me I'm so excited I even want to
explore it what is this idea like how do
I get into that that's that's like when
you write into like because I I the list
I'm pretty sure your phone is just
[ __ ] I'm right sometimes but this
when you're writing it you're like oh
[ __ ] like I just put it yeah I know it's
gonna be there yeah and just trying to
do it just talking to people about it
like I don't know like for me it's like
I now I want to know yeah like now I
want to know every now I want to know
more about like Jewish people like like
sit down yeah are you circumcised yeah
you wanna you wanna
I'm circumcised too I'm all right
welcome to dude he still has the skin
it's on my neck my necklace there it is
a little piece of animals that's what
arugula is they just wrap them
what's in the soup yeah
just a comedian meaning yeah yeah like
we had Antonio Brown on right yeah we
could talk about and we're like I don't
know if you saw the interview heard
about it whatever but yeah we're like oh
there's a football players I'm more than
a football player I'm a father it's like
all right some people I'm a businessman
LeBron is like I'm not just a basketball
player I'm a businessman but like
there's something beautiful and being a
comedian it's like I am just straight up
comedian I think there's a business
stuff there's actor there's this but how
would you define yourself in that regard
yeah I'm a comedian I I don't need
comedy to be important matter of fact
the less importance you put on it the
better like I I don't I I am just a
comedian and I make dick jokes matter of
fact the less you think of what I do
yeah the more I can do uncircumcised
dictates exactly exactly but you know so
it's like the more importance we put on
Comedy the less we can say you know
there's Comics all the time that that
they they're saying these things I'm
sure I'm guilty of saying as well but
like comedy is so important it's the
last Bastion of free speech and all
these other things and you know without
Comics we would devolve into communism
and then they also go like why is
everyone starting to silence us it's
like because you're saying you're
important yeah shut up if you just say
that you're a clown you can say whatever
you want and then if there is some truth
in it they can't help but get that in
there you think Bill Maher's still a
comedian
yeah yeah I think Bill is Jon Stewart
John is John You could argue
John You could argue is so good at what
he did he ruined it for everybody
because John
John made political comedy
seem like that was what you were
supposed to do he was so good at it and
he was so like pure about like John
stops his show and he's still like no
we're gonna get these firefighters there
their [ __ ] pay we're gonna get them
there sure like even if he's not doing
it he's about that life so but John was
so good at the political comedy it
almost made I think a whole generation
of people expect their comedy to be
political when in my opinion like
sometimes it has to be sometimes it
isn't I don't ever tell people what side
I'm on I don't ever want them to know
like because maybe I don't have a side I
want I want Republicans to be like oh
yeah he says some [ __ ] that I and I want
Democrats to be like oh [ __ ] and I want
them both to be upset at me like there's
an abortion joke I do in the special and
in the comments both people on the side
have no clue how I feel about abortion
perfect so it's like to me that's the
superpower but in order to have the
superpower you have to wear the mask
because they know who you are then
they're gonna [ __ ] with you you know
what I mean it's like for me that's
where you can be the most pure version
of a comic and that's right and mind
you've talked about Trump you've made
fun of Biden you're just bro and it's
good I know when people ask especially
with me I'm just like because my cousins
are liberals but hard yeah hardcore
falling the sword they're like well
video when you're Republican like whoa I
don't vote I don't I'm just I'm in I'm
on one of those little Raffles but you
know just in the in the river just go
I'm on the side of jokes that's what I
said like I'm loyal I'm loyal to these
jokes and if I feel a certain way about
the world I'm gonna Express that do you
think that the jokes that you're able to
tell the comedians are able to tell you
think that it's better content now with
Biden or better content when Trump was
in office
that's an interesting question because I
think that
I think that people
either they're not aware of it
or they're not willing to admit it
but I think that people are actually
happier with Biden in office
and not right or left I think they're
happier being less engaged
everybody's been able to kind of like
disconnect a little bit and with Trump
he has this unbelievable magnetism
that
whether you like it or not you're going
to react
the guy talks and you react
and I think what happened with that is
it went Trump
then coveted
and we were just like sensory overload
and everything that we were told became
[ __ ] three weeks later you know what
I'm saying like every little bit of
information we got
was not exactly true and I don't know if
you guys went through this but I just
kind of like removed myself I was
exhaustion I'm not reading another
exhaustion bro I read an article once it
was a whole article right and like I
read and it was like you know the adds
kicking in I'm like reading and I'm like
having a hypothetical fight with my wife
she doesn't even know about and then I
gotta come back to the same other
[ __ ] top of the article four
different times I restart this art I get
to the bottom of the article I'm like I
[ __ ] read that whole article about
some [ __ ] I don't even care about I got
this I'm a citizen of America you know
what's going on the first [ __ ] blurb
at the bottom of the article is like
some information in this article has
been refuted blah blah yeah I don't need
you to [ __ ] it yeah put it at the top
you know how many times
I never get that time back I have all
this new information and it's useless
wow
so I so I weirdly think
I think that like I think people feel
two ways I think people are probably
embarrassed about Biden I think people
are way more entertained by Trump I
think regardless of where their
political beliefs lie
and I don't care who the [ __ ] you are
everybody agrees with a little bit of
what [ __ ] Trump says and everybody
agrees a little bit of what buys there's
no person it's like I only believe the
same thing one man believe like I don't
but I wouldn't believe if you but
I think the temperature is cooler the
tricky thing now is that
Biden's so old and so obviously dealing
with cognitive issues cognitive bare
minimum cognitive issues right he can't
say a number that's more than four
digits yeah Hey listen Andrew two words
if it's more than four different made in
America yeah
he's in America in two words like
honestly he might be more entertaining
than Trump if you really think about it
who's the best in person who doesn't
best it's Trump I mean you had Alec
Baldwin you had all these uh Frank
Caliendo who does Biden I can't even
know those bikes
the face swap it's brilliant it's
brilliant how done again because he says
the same mistakes words and uh but then
yo but Andrew like real talk and Pat we
talked about this Trump a lot of people
are like man just the Santa in the truck
I saw a rally he's not done he's not
only running
coming back you don't think Trump has
the Party by the balls Pat who July
Trump oh there's no question about it
yeah because even if even if he doesn't
win the primary he'll run as an
independent that's right there you go
that's right so they got to give him the
nomination if they want
if they want to win and and Republicans
get organized right they get in line
here's the difference here's the
difference if you think about a couple
things what is the biggest difference
between so okay so this is the question
to ask
give five reasons why he won in 2016
okay
why he won so you could say a person you
could say uh whatever give five reasons
why you think Trump won in 2016. five
reasons all of us together
but why he won yeah humor okay humor's
one uh because the person who's going
against Hillary did all that stupid [ __ ]
okay you know so so right there so let's
just say a terrible opponent that's
terrible what else give another one why
he won uh the Celebrity Status his uh
okay friendship coverage yeah just news
constant coverage by everybody okay yep
and then what else
okay fine you put that one as well that
five was money I think there was a deep
year I think you guys were missing a
couple things or something yeah out of
the swamp
whether it was Bernie or whether it was
Trump yeah just not your typical
politician yeah I think they're Hillary
that robotic yeah I'm with her I'm just
there was a resentment
what do my handlers tell me to say yeah
where Trump is like handlers check out
these hands I'm grabbing by the [ __ ]
right now I'm giving [ __ ] like it's also
a lot of people who like have felt we
were talking about this like there's a
lot of people who just felt completely
forgotten and
and when you give a nod to people who
feel forgotten
they can look past all the other dubious
[ __ ] that you say because finally
you're being spoken to okay yeah can I
give you a couple mine please check this
out okay so so here's here's the real if
we were if let's just say Trump right
now called us in the middle of the
podcast said guys I've made a decision I
want to hire you guys as our campaign
manager the four of you you guys are
helping us up yes
Malik for sure because he's got to do
Google he's got to search up yeah a
black guy so so so here's here's what
you got so you said comedy you said
Hillary bad opponent you said he's a
Celebrity Apprentice you said the
coverage by everybody and you got money
okay so what's the same he's still funny
but little bitter yes before he was
funny he's bitter now he wasn't bitter
back then right I agree he was an
underdog there's a different energy
between Underdog coming up yeah versus a
bitter that Underdog energy is gone yeah
so there's no longer that Underdog
Spirit right that if you think about the
underdog correct because he's like oh
you're doubting me now it's like so does
he does he still have the money yes does
he still have a bad opponent he's going
to go up against yes there's still a bad
opponent so is he still a celebrity yes
is he still gonna get coverage no no
he's not going to get shot there's no
way he's going to get the same CNN MSNBC
have them on another lesson so that's
gone right now here's a couple other
things
kellyanne Conway was one of his best
flight carriers he lost her she's not
doing it this time she's gone she would
go on MSNBC CNN they would invite her
and she would defend him better than
anybody else that one is gone the next
thing that's gone he said he's not
coming back to Twitter because when he
did the SPAC deal I'm willing to bet if
I gave Trump a few hundred million
dollars I'm only paying your spack if I
tell you one rule will give you this uh
200 million dollars whatever the amount
was that they gave him for this pack you
will never tweet as long even if they
let you back on you will not use Twitter
so he said I'm not going to be using
Twitter just come to truth so Twitter is
gone wow here's the other one that's
gone you ready uh is there a is there an
alternative to him at that time who uh
Huckabee a Rubio Jeb Bush Scott Walker
Ben Carson crew Ted Cruz
Ron Paul Kasich so but there is an
alternative today you're right so that
is the part and it's a real alternative
that's an option right that
you have to look at the drama does he
have Facebook today no does he have
YouTube today no does he have his
daughter today no right his daughter
said I'm not part of the campaign I'm
out so so so the part that you have to
kind of think about and then Schwartzman
I don't know if you guys know powerful
Schwartzman yeah he said I'm not I'm not
supporting Schwartzman Schwartzman is a
in the financial space this guy's a uh
uh right there Schwartzman is the CEO
Blackstone Group Blackstone he said I'm
not supporting this guy's worth 30
billion 40 billion what's his number
right here zoom in a little bit [ __ ]
27.5 billion dude this is a guy that's
straight up went against Rahm Emanuel
and went against you know Obama and
wasn't afraid so the the challenge with
all of this stuff yep he doesn't have
the same team as he did before and there
is a real alternative today so yeah you
don't have the same Playbook today as he
did in 2016. now here's the flip side of
it so like when you you know when you're
like well you I don't ever want people
to think I'm a you know where I'm at
politically let them kind of guessing
game all that stuff we like I think
Biden's a good thing which I understand
what you're saying but you know the
moment Mackenzie Scott left a crazy
Visionary like Jeff Bezos are married a
school teacher within a year she got a
divorce because she got tired of the
boring safe stuff okay but uh you know
you're still dealing with a guy
that is a flipping fighter who's you
know like he will the level of
relentlessness this guy's got there is
nobody at his level in politics
just nobody at his level he's
intimidating he'll get dirty with you
he'll talk trash to you he'll tell you
what nobody else is wanting to tell you
he'll he'll entertain he'll talk he can
go for hours talking on stage without a
uh what he call a teleprompter all these
other guys are teleprompter driven they
need script writers this guy doesn't you
know when you're saying how he did a
special and he got up and he started
first talking to the crowd good luck
where's the teleprompter half the guys
need somebody to write the script they
need a writer for them comedian this
guy's getting up there saying you know
I've seen him in a private event
multiple times in Mar-A-Lago with the
thing off
and I tell you you know George two hours
you're laughing thirty percent of the
time forty percent of the time you're
literally in tears laughing I love it
you're like this you could have been a
comedian this year 100 and he just goes
no teleprompter oh my God who can do
that today honestly can the scientists
do that no no he can't do that can
Newsome do that no can Biden do it for
half a second no no can Kamala do it can
Peach do it can Rubio do it can Cruz do
it none of these guys have that ability
to get up and light it up and 50 000
people show up so as much as it's very
easy for people to say Let it Loose you
know no way in the world all this other
stuff you have to deal with Trump period
so if he doesn't run as a republican
runs as an independent if I'm if I'm a
like right now DeSantis is playing the
card of just staying quiet not saying
anything back not talking [ __ ] not
retaliating not rebuttling nothing's
been said yet but he has announced that
his autobiography is coming out for uh
DeSantis anytime you have an
autobiography like when yours comes up
we know you're running for office just
so you know is that true yeah yeah you
and your autobiography what if he's like
I'm actually in the middle of right now
you said that you know you know you know
what it is going to be here's a perfect
title for your book and I'm telling you
I think the moment I say it the moment I
said you're gonna say that's the title
you ready circumcised
foreign
[Laughter]
a little Heat
to to what to want to get in there and
go by the way he wants in he wants it do
you think he does you think he really
wanted something there's there's two
things that never lies man did you just
never look at the guy's eyes yeah eyes
Never Lie yeah this guy wants it like
you have no clue he wants that fight he
doesn't want it to be easy he wants to
go up against a guy like that as
brilliant as he is as strategic as he is
he wants that oh you think he wants no I
think he wants that fight he is a
soldier boy he's a soldier I think you
know like uh you know how boxers get
criticized for not wanting to fight the
other opponent that they were at the he
wants to beat Trump
at his best like he wants him he wants
them now that's my opinion I may be
fully off and I may be like because if I
think who he is I don't think he wants
to be a guy to become a president easily
like he's like well let me tell you how
we did it we got rid of him we got rid
of oh here's the sentence what a lame
story you kidding me Trump's story like
looking what just happened yesterday
we're upstairs I'm in a business meeting
one Colombian Sam runs in a Guatemalan
Mario runs in we're like oh Mexico won
they're advancing no they're not because
Argentina won 2-0 Mexico was supposed to
win 2-0 yeah two minutes left stoppage
time you know Saudi Arabia scores a goal
Mexico's out and I'm like are you
kidding me but the Mexicans are now
watching World Cup they're done
immediately forget about the coach got
fired that thing was that that comeback
of what just happened there that's a
that's a tough loss right oh my God
think about the most incredible losses
like how the Red Sox came out and beat
the Yankees that's a pain you look at
how you know Atlanta lost to Brady oh my
28-3 you think about you know all these
games dude nothing comes close with what
Trump did to Hillary that night like
it's 3 30 in the morning you just
enjoyed watching these people cry yeah I
did such a freaking entertainment bro so
I I think if this guy wants to truly be
a heavyweight and he wants to be like a
reagan-esque type of a guy he's got to
take out Trump and how
the how he's got the right people that
are sharing Insight on how to do it
this guy is uh he's he he's he's not
gonna have a hard time doing it in his
eyes he's not gonna have a hard time
doing it however
um so I'll give you some strategies in
my opinion and then you know it is what
it is so look at
for example okay
you walk into a room you're negotiating
with an enemy
okay and you know this guy's an [ __ ]
he doesn't like you he's bigger than you
and he's been bullying you and he's
constantly talking [ __ ] to you
when you walk into this meeting you have
a few different options option number
one be diplomatic yeah and you go in and
you say hey John how are you everything
good hey thank you for making the time
it's great to be here with you okay now
to him you're kissing his ass all right
it's fake number two you show up eight
minutes late
okay big dick yeah and then you're like
oh hey what's up hey can you do me a
favor can you tell them we got to leave
in 20 minutes I okay so what's up tell
me I know you want to figure this thing
out obviously we have some issues here
what do you want to do I'm not convinced
you want to do anything here with us so
go ahead I'm all yours go ahead you can
take that route
he can't come in be like hey you know he
has to send handlers to have those types
of conversation both of them are having
their handlers talk to each other
but you eventually have to face off
against the guy privately and have the
conversation and
he's not going to take the Mark Rubio
route if he does he'll get destroyed if
he takes the Ted Cruz Rod he's going to
get destroyed what are those Mark Rubio
route was the route where
he's uh uh uh starts off you know being
very diplomatic and then all of a sudden
he tries to you know play The Game of
Thrones
you're not in this league bro yeah and
then everybody's like dude you're not
yeah it's not your game bro don't play
this game like you know SportsZone
you're a shooter you try to play in the
inside again that's not your game yeah
keep shooting the threes that's your
game Golden State play that game
this guy has to come out guns blazing
and setting his argument and letting
everybody know uh but at the same time
given the message in a way knowing he's
still gonna need the mega voters to
support him to win office yeah yeah so
it is a very
massaging you know like you have to
maneuver you have to push you have to
bully it you have to respect he he's got
his work cut out for him but if there's
a guy that could pull it off it's him
does it bother you
that currently you can't run for
president
does it bother who you me yeah what a
question you're asking
if I can't run for president yeah I
don't think it bothers me I think
I think it's not your choice everything
else in your life so far as an idea has
been your choice
listen some people are put there to help
somebody else do it meaning maybe one of
my kids is going to be a president and
my job is to help change their mindset
yeah yeah maybe I'm a Joe Kennedy maybe
I'm a uh Fred maybe I'm a Prescott maybe
I'm that guy and I'm very comfortable
playing that role yeah because I'm you
know this this is a area I enjoy the
king maker part of the game yeah I
enjoyed the other night we're having a
conversation until one o'clock in the
morning five hours I'm having a
conversation with this guy because I
really think this guy is super capable
of what he can do we've had multiple few
hour conversations sitting there talking
to Jedediah seeing what she's doing
right now our insurance company seeing
what our guys are doing I freaking love
that part of the game oh my God but like
naturally but a little bit oh president
yeah I would vote let me I think you
I'll be honest I think you could do it
let me let me give you one if you're
asking me like what laws I would change
if I was a uh well you can't do it
Constitution wise here's what it would
be
I think there are people that love
America more who weren't born here yeah
of course of course and I think the if
you wanted to really still keep the
Integrity of 35 years do it 35 years
from the day you came here or 35 years
from the day you became a citizen let
that be the same as somebody that has
lived here for 35 years I think that law
logically makes sense to me if they did
something like that that law makes sense
and I think being in the military should
give you a little bit more incentive
because you've served and fought for
this place so that should give you
another okay knock off five years he's
Gucci that's what I I mean yeah I don't
I don't know I don't know I mean I know
a lot of people that love America but
Pat's up there is one of the
pro-american pro-capitalist pro so let's
say they change it
let's say it changes the rule what about
it
if they change it I see a smirk if they
change it
I I'm I'll be straight this is the first
time I'm talking about on the podcast
like this if they changed it very high
likelihood I would entertain running
yeah
[Laughter]
sit down Anderson Cooper yeah
that see that's interesting that's
interesting no you're one of the first
guys that um
that I that I actually like that I would
say well I don't want you to run because
I don't want them to just tear apart
your family and you go through all these
things but but yeah I get a good sense
from you that you you genuinely want to
help
and I think that's what I got from
Bernie it was like I didn't agree with
almost any of his philosophy but I
thought he wanted to help not win
and unfortunately you need to want to
win in order to win but that resonated
with me I was like I think this guy just
wants to do the best thing and maybe he
and I differ on what the best thing is
but at least his heart is in the right
place and this is America they're not
going to let you change too much [ __ ] so
I was like I [ __ ] with that guy for that
reason that was like a rare thing it was
also interesting like him and Trump
resonate at the same time which speaks
you were talking about earlier which was
like this dissatisfaction yeah the
political system and then these two
Outsiders and because of the corrupt
nature of the way Democratic primaries
work and [ __ ] super delegates which
is like a mind-boggling concept that
they even exists but uh you know he
wasn't able to get there and it was kind
of You could argue stolen for whoever he
wasn't able to get it but like seeing
both of those people represented it was
Trump and Bernie at the same time spoke
volumes to what Americans wanted mm-hmm
right yep and by the way they should
have faced off they should have they
should have faced out I agree because
both of them are True Believers and they
should have faced off and what is
Hillary got in the way and Biden gotten
both times but what is Trump going to
say about Bernie oh like what can he say
that's the thing it's like
Trump is fascinating because and I think
Ben Shapiro put this the best he's like
politics is a mudslinging competition
and and uh Trump is made of mud yeah wow
everybody else is in their white suit
you know what I mean so that mud shows
up way more for sure or what do they say
that you know never uh
mud wrestle with the pig because you
both get dirty you know Pig loves it
exactly guys go make it in real estate
in New York for 50 years you can see
what happens to you
hook up with everybody that he hooked up
would date a bunch of models have the
pressure of a father that you had with a
mother who was so flamboyant and he
picked up that site from her have your
older brother die from alcohol and then
see what kind of a person you would be
this this guy is
this guy is a ridiculous guy yeah this
this uh the the the resume and the
pedigree that he has and and being from
the streets of going up against all
these guys that are trying to bully you
no look it's very hard to be in
someone's Shadow yeah very hard to be on
someone's Shadow as a kid yeah by the
way secretly
I I don't know how much more resentment
there is
then you doing good in your life and you
would have been a superstar if anybody
was your father then put a superstar as
a father dude that's that's not like a
easy thing to like imagine you're dating
your girl your new girl are dating each
other you're going out and you just may
partner at a law firm that's freaking
badass in New York to 31 you're the
youngest party made 1.8 million last
year
and you go home and your dad's there and
your wife's like man your dad man it's
freaking amazing guy and what he does
can you like relax I'm a freaking
partner yeah well your dad's three
billion dollars yeah yeah like think
about how annoying that can be right to
be able to have your father Fred Trump
with the badass eyebrows have you seen
French like caterpillars Legend pull up
Brett Trump's eyebrows I mean these were
aggressive this is like one of us are
running for US
dude this is like uh so that's not even
a good picture of eyebrows there's
another one that's phenomenal you could
braid his eyebrows I mean this is a
cornrow so but the point is look at that
picture right there look at that picture
right there I mean you can tell yeah so
look at that look at that right there
yeah they're [ __ ] up I mean you Trump
suit
you gotta and then you outdo him that's
in every way that's crazy that's that's
not easy to do yeah so it's not easy to
do now he's a force man he's a force but
I'm so curious about what about Governor
no what about going to fix California
I'm good man you don't want to fix
California no no interest not at all let
me explain to you why let me explain to
one and hopefully this will make like
for example Florida yeah you know we got
a couple guys here they're like Pat we
all know you're going to run for I'm
like dude you I'm telling you right now
it would really have to be like I would
say less than one percent chance I run
Governor State of Florida okay why
here's the way I processed it okay
um if I want to put the family and the
kids through anything I'm not gonna put
it through for governor I'd go help
somebody be a governor I would help them
but I'm not going to put my family
through that part if it is where the
influence can be to really make an
impact as a nation no problem let's go
it's going to be ugly it's going to be
nasty but we're going to be all right
we'll prep everybody that would be more
worth it than doing something that's a
governor not worth it like even business
lateral damage it's it's just it's uh
yeah it's it's not it's you know it's
kind of it's it's just doesn't exist I
think California is ready I thought
California I thought who was it what was
it in that election my boy Dove was was
uh he had feelings about that who just
lost what's the guy's name oh and Cali
yeah in L.A no is uh the mayor oh the
what's his name the Rick Ross
who beat him he lost to who he lost to a
lady I believe yeah I thought L.A was
fed up but you know dude by the way they
were fed up a lot of people that are
friends who are in Hollywood who were
supporting this guy who were like you
know we want a Caruso to win and you
know he's a republican that ran as a
Democrat so that was a great way of
doing it but uh you know even with the
recall with Newsom he still won 63 yeah
I mean it's not like it was uh was close
yeah you asking questions that you may
even have some interest in this is there
any interest with you with politics no
zero at all
nobody but you listen you you've just
seen what's happened the last few years
with
the model of a comedian winning you know
like
Trump tell people what to do man I wanna
I love influencing culture for sure and
I love doing that in a in a you know
with with humor and sometimes I like to
tell jokes about absolutely nothing but
um but yeah life taking part in culture
that's really interesting to me but
you know not I don't want to tell people
how to live and I want and I'm too
empathetic for like how both people and
both sides want to live because I
ultimately think that they want the same
thing they don't just they don't even
realize that they're trying to fight for
the same thing you know you could take
even like the most divisive issue it's
like like you know with the Trans kids
or whatever like that like getting and
it's like both sides are actually like
caring about the kids like the the
liberal side are going like oh my God
these poor kids are having this identity
crisis and what can we do to make them
more comfortable and then the
conservative side is going oh my God
these poor kids could be influenced to
do something trendy that could
permanently ruin them what a point but
like both parents are concerned about
those [ __ ] kids man so it's like and
and you never get a discussion
where you can just have them agree
because the way that we pin things is
you know both sides are evil and you
want to destroy whatever so I don't know
I think the the coolest thing would be
able to be to have people on the podcast
or have discussions even like we're
having right now and then have people be
able to go oh [ __ ] yeah that other side
isn't that bad and maybe the heart's
kind of in the you know right place but
they're just coming at it from a
different direction it becomes very
tricky and maybe you have way more
experiences from running businesses
where you have to make decisions that
are going to affect people and you have
to make a decision it's going to affect
x amount of people that work for you and
they're going to disagree with it and
like be upset by it and that's a
listen as much as we criticize
politicians as much as we're like upset
at them as much as we're angry about
things making decisions is hard
and living with the consequences of
those decisions is hard and I respect
that
ability even if I disagree with the
decision made because most people would
prefer not to
that that is a brave thing you know you
look at like military decisions like you
pushing a [ __ ] button and sending
some guys in somewhere that's a tough
thing yeah I imagine yep
that takes a [ __ ] man to make that
decision man woman I don't care whatever
when I'm saying man I'm talking about
someone who's willing to stand on it
that's a [ __ ] tough thing to do now
we could criticize those all we want
sitting back here but given you're in
that situation what are you gonna do you
freeze yeah you're gonna freeze I mean
look natural behavior you know most
people are afraid of breakups they're
afraid of people leaving them they're
afraid of not being liked they're afraid
of uh people uh you know what if I lose
this person because maybe they didn't
have a father figure in their lives or a
mom or a bad relationship with an ex who
left them or cheated or whatever it is
there's these fears that that you have
right
you you you're gonna have a very hard
time leading making decisions if those
things concern you but by the way Rogan
said something to you that he's 100
right
dude things change when you have a kid
it's a very weird thing Malik's got a
kid he knows what I'm talking about
things change two kids yeah when color
no
what movie is that where the kid is like
the white guy
oh my God is it me myself and Iris yeah
you know but I thought I thought it was
another one as well that that I'm trying
to see what movie that was with the is
it George Clooney or George Clooney and
uh and uh that Zach Galifianakis were at
the end anyways there's a funny movie
comedy that that happens at the end but
that's you're right maybe once
that's so interesting maybe once you
have children you go
oh I need to do something about this to
protect to protect you to protect
because it's natural that's that makes
more sense to me I guess where I'm at
the situation right now it's like where
I'm like I don't want to tell people
what to do and I love that this society
that we've built where we can have this
fun and we can play we can also say
serious things we can influence and
maybe like through that influence you
know who knows I made us some Silly [ __ ]
about Tick Tock but then all of a sudden
maybe the conversation that maybe could
get it kicked out of here which is maybe
a safer thing for America and that'd be
pretty cool yeah and I like playing that
part but you know even earlier when we
were looking at 40 Laws of Power the
whole you're like you're able to be
neutral see both sides you're willing
accepting of both sides and you're able
to reason these are all great qualities
of a leader and where you are right now
do it let a rip let life uh life's gonna
happen marriage is interesting having
kids is interesting and all of a sudden
it's different when you have a son you
know it's different when you have a
daughter you know it's going to be a
very very a different feeling with a
daughter or a son you know and those
Dynamics are in an age and then
conversations with them we're like dude
this guy's so different than this guy
and how do I lead him versus her and you
know that's scary when you have kids
like um
like
accepting the lack of influence you have
over them because you can't be with them
every second of every day and they're
going to be influenced by their peers
and the movie like do you have to just
let go a bit
can you
you don't have a choice
you don't have a chance right yeah you
don't have a choice with that so it's so
so you know what the number one decision
is the number one decision is who you
marry yeah you know when you're when
you're talking to her at one of the you
know say you're dating her for six
months or 12 months yeah and you're
sitting there saying okay
I like you yeah we're cool would you
make a good mom yeah and and if you
would make a good mom what would you
teach my kids how would you be what
would be uh like you know you're talking
about uh Kelly and Conway and George
Conway and their daughter getting on
videos and showing what the life looks
like dude first of all you guys screwed
up right off the bed when you guys don't
even agree on you know basic politics I
mean what are you doing right off the
bat you're teaching the the kid is
looking at this oh they disagree okay
I'm gonna lean on that I'm going to lean
on Mom and then boom I come out so the
number one thing is who you marry and
then from there is you being clear on
seeing what your mom and dad did that
you liked you didn't like it like this
[ __ ] didn't work that didn't work this
definitely didn't work I didn't like it
but it was very good because it worked
on me I needed this and then eventually
and this is the biggest part the the
reason why you're gonna like making
money is you have the resources to put a
team together around you period when you
when you have the money you get to
decide what Nanny you get to decide what
private school you get to decide what
sports team you get to decide which
coach you get to decide you have
resources you have resources the benefit
of having resources to do that and then
people that are around you say if we're
working together your kids coming around
me you're like I'm just thinking I would
Pat all my kids going around you I know
what Andrew's going to talk to them
about
that you're vetting the parents oh 100
interesting 100 you're 100 that's
interesting Andrew when did you get
married uh December 18th last year so
you're about to have your one year
anniversary yeah and you're and you're
trying to have a kid we just started
yeah okay yeah because like you're
lighting up right now asking these
questions you could tell he's
inquisitive very important because he's
in the moment when somebody who's done
it it's kind of like what we were
talking about earlier with the red pill
stuff where you're like
talk to me when you get married if you
want to just be a guy single guy
Bachelor for sure soak it all in but
there's another level to it right yeah
and then there's another level until you
want to be a father right who's the
actor that you love that's going to play
you in a movie one day
he's got a podcast it's awesome yeah
that's great he's sitting there with um
Shia LaBeouf yeah yeah and he says uh
you know when do you become a man when
do you become a man right he says you
become a man when you become responsible
for somebody else this is life right
yeah because so now when you're you're a
husband now right because Schultz and I
used to be hanging with the twins type
thing you know now you respond no you
know what I'm saying now you're
responsible for your girl right but then
that's one level yeah then there's
another level of being responsible for a
kid yeah and like all there's different
levels to this yeah so when Pat is
responsible for four kids his wife his
father lives in the house yeah Melville
who's the maid and then and then
the people so it's it's sponge it up is
what I'm saying because for me yeah I
mean curiosity is I think that my most
valuable trait to be honest you know but
um and there's just a lot you can learn
from people who have had those
experiences but yeah I'm just fascinated
by it like even getting even getting
married like there's there's being in
love with somebody and uh there's also
wanting to build a family like I didn't
want to just get married I told my wife
I was like whether the government knows
we're married or not I don't give a [ __ ]
I mean if you care yeah but what I'm
doing to you is I'm going I want to
build a family with you
and um I knew I knew she was right I
weirdly I went to a bookstore with my my
uh wife on our like fourth date actually
and uh I picked out a book and I and I
gave it to her and um it was the karma
sutra of you
yo in my head I was like he reads books
president
oh my God he's so good
yo he got me so good wow
he's a reader
mostly pictures this is mostly pictures
this one so here's what I like yeah
that's so funny no but that for real
like we have those songs like I want to
build a family and like I want to like
you know I want to do I want to pass on
the ship my father gave to me you know
my dad's my hero so I you know I always
think about every decision I make
I have this person where I get to go
well what would he have done in that
decision like every tough thing that I
go through I go well how would he have
handled it and um I want to be able to
be that for my kids you know but yeah
you know God willing I think I think you
I think you'll be just mind you I'm like
I'm kind of like Adam I don't I mean I
don't have not kind of like I am like
Adam no kids but just talking to you and
seeing you and just you'll be you're
gonna be fine bro and you learn as you
go and it'll be dope page seven you'll
be good bro
my man anyways this has been a blast
yeah of a podcast I'm glad we got
together this was unbelievable thank you
so much before we wrap up can I can I
give a just a like a you know yeah go
for it go ahead PSA uh so yeah love you
brother that's nothing to do with you so
yeah this is more for the audience out
here but we were talking about Tate
earlier oh yeah yeah so um we did a
whole podcast we've had a great
experience with him yeah it was a huge
that podcast so the first uh podcast
that uh I think he did right after
um he was banned we had a great time it
was awesome Brave move by the way Brave
move and it worked out well I know he
speaks very highly of Pat we speak very
highly of him I've said nothing but good
things about Andrew Tate you know I did
a where am I going with this uh we all
look at
podcasts we do we're jokes with
comedians what have you and well you
know if you ever played sports or do
comedy we you get a mulligan every once
in a while if you could get them all
again you look back and you're like
could have done that one better could
have done that one better you've been
there before I'm sure so I did a podcast
with this guy called snico yes um two
weeks ago let's say and let's just say
it could have gone better I should have
been nicer genuinely it just should have
been nicer yeah be nice and in the
context of this um
podcast I was you know reaching and
trying to you know uh find common ground
with this guy and I said some things
about Tate in uh in the hopes that we
were kind of bond over something and in
that process I kind of said more than I
should have I'm not going to get into
the details now but I said more than I
should have and uh when someone trusts
you with something a secret we take that
very seriously around here I take that
very seriously and I said something that
I shouldn't have and uh I know that he
wasn't probably happy about that so
um
one of the things I learned from Tate
for sure sitting down with him was
taking accountability and personal
responsibility one of the hardest things
to do is look in a mirror and be like
dude you [ __ ] up dude like everyone's
been no no you don't understand it's
like no I I messed up real big time so
um I want to take a second to give me a
Copa an apology and I'm sorry
um to to Tate for sure good of you to
Pat Curry yes courage yeah that's right
there and to pack because I kind of put
you in the in the middle of this
apologizing to Andrew salts because uh
you're in the middle of this now Vinnie
um generally I think if you if you need
to apologize for taking a piece of my
dick skin yeah you freaking Rap God
so anyway that too but we all make
mistakes man we all make mistakes and I
think the true test of a man is to own
up to a mistake and say you know what I
screwed up and and when you do own up to
it and give an apology and um and move
on you're a good man last but not least
apologizing to the audience out there
because we do try to do the best thing
possible and deliver real good product
that we do value your opinions and if
there's anyone I pissed off by saying
things I shouldn't have I have the
deepest apologies but um good on you
sorry you're a good man perfect not easy
to do that no it's not easy to do and we
talked about it on the flight back and
we said hey here's how it is and you
know and you're you're Manning up to it
so I respect that yeah but uh awesome
okay good you're good with that yeah
thank you proud of you man okay uh
anyways this was sick this was awesome
felt like five minutes dude you're
freaking amazing I gotta tell you got a
fan here man big fan of what you're
doing well I got more questions for you
so one of these days you're gonna get
blown
the weirdest thing about sitting in
podcasts like this is when you've
watched someone online so many times and
you're like I think I like that person
but you don't know yeah and then you
come in and it's like oh we're homies
and it's like I'm also a fan and it's
also like you know you know I'm pissed
off about this [ __ ] because I'm like
his fourth day and it's beautiful I'm
like what bookstore is
thing and then you just [ __ ] you just
took that left and I go this piece
or helped out or helpful because he
knows he sat down with the doctor that
said a story again
we're all like what book what busted I
wasn't invested I was like you [ __ ] but
y'all it was amazing that was awesome
well if you're gonna do your next
special when you decide to do the next
special yeah let us make an offer on it
let us make an offer on it call us let
us know we'd love to talk to you about
that but uh with that being said I don't
know we don't have another podcast this
week we are Monday we're with Michael
Saylor that's right which means on
Monday just so everybody knows we're
gonna ask four questions Michael's gonna
talk for two hours yeah we're gonna talk
for 30 seconds so just come to find out
what those four questions are because we
got to talk about Sam bankman freet and
what the hell he just did with New York
Times
Please Subscribe flagrant yes check out
flagrant man check it out please thank
you my man take care everybody have a
great weekend bye bye bye bye